Three,
two,
one.
John Ronson.
Welcome back Joe.
It's good to be back.
Good to see you again.
Very good to be back.
What's happening,
man?
How you been?
I've been good.
A floating around this neighborhood.
Yeah.
I've spent a year on porn sets,
research,
research.
It did,
it was a lot.
My wife did say to me once a twisty
really liked you really have to go to
another.
Uh,
it,
uh,
I've just,
I've just finished making a series for
audible called the butterfly effect and
the flap of the butterfly's wings,
which I'm tracing throughout the series
is um,
is this young man called Fabian who's
like a tech nerd in Brussels and he has
the idea to get rich from giving the
world free porn.
So free streaming porn.
So the series is about the kind of tech
takeover of porn in the valley.
I know that that's the real.
Oh No,
this one's everywhere.
Yeah,
no,
that was bad.
That was back in the day that I was like
in the nineties.
So Fabian Fabian gave the world pornhub
and fiction.
No,
no,
this is,
this is so true.
So.
Okay,
I'll let me go back.
So in the nineties,
this kid called Fabian Fabian Tillman as
a young boy in Brussels,
like a tech nerd,
uh,
would let go and compuserve and swap
porn and so get porn for free like that,
which is how people got for back in the
nineties.
Um,
and then he had like a sort of Eureka
moment,
which is I can,
I can give the world youtube for porn.
Right?
So he brought up this fledgling company
in Montreal called uh,
um,
it was called Mansef at the time.
It was run by these two brothers up in
Montreal and they had just invented
Pornhub,
uh,
Fabian bought a porn hub and then kind
of overnight singlehandedly took over
the valley.
The,
it's an extraordinary story.
This massive flow of money went from
where we are now in the valley,
a community of people who were making
pretty good money from porn.
The money just load into Fabian's
pocket,
uh,
because what Fabian did was,
um,
well look,
if you're,
if you're a porn star and you go to a
bank and say,
can I have a checking account?
You see a porn star or porn stir upon,
well,
I said a porn star,
but actually there aren't really many
porn stars anymore.
If you're a poor person and you go to a
bank and he say,
can I have a checking account?
The bank manager will usually say no
because you're in porn,
which means your disreputable.
Really?
Yes.
People,
people like story.
I've written about this a lot about how
they found it really hard to get
mortgages.
How did they find it?
Hard to get checking accounts with
checking accounts.
That seems unlikely.
I mean I would.
That may be mortgages.
They would think that your business is
fairly unstable.
That kind of makes sense as far as
investments are concerned
and also the idea that other people have
the customers might not like the idea
that are high street bank is being
shared with somebody who's in bone.
Really?
Yes.
Go reputational risk.
Wow.
That seems really dumb to me.
Doesn't make any sense at all.
Right?
Well,
sure.
Um,
but Fabian was making money from running
a site that doubt in the,
in,
in piracy.
So the funds would upload pole and
illegally onto pornhub.
So Fabian was running this site that was
failed with pirated content.
Uh,
Fabian went to a bank to say I want to
expand,
but because he wasn't extensively a poor
person,
he was a tech person who was deemed to
be respectable.
This bank gave him a $362,000,000
loan to expand,
uh,
to build an empire based in part on the
handling of stolen porn.
So we went to the valley who will,
who already kind of paranoid that all
poor and was being stolen and put up
onto pornhub and he bought up all the
loads of companies that cut price
because the companies were like
panicking.
I wanted to sell.
I'm certainly fabian just single
handedly,
like took her for porn.
Um,
so I wanted,
and nobody cares about that.
Nobody was thinking about the
consequences of that because Fabian was
given the world what they wanted to.
It's risk free porn.
Um,
but I was really curious to know level,
but when it comes to let me know.
Pause there.
You said no one cares about it.
No,
but a lot of people did.
It was a huge issue and there was a lot
of like moral debate around weapons
stopping poem,
you know,
there's a lot of the girls that were in
porn that were really pissed off because
they weren't making any money anymore
and they were,
there was a lot of social media posts
about it imploring people to stop using
these sites,
which no one listened to.
Exactly.
People cat pulled and consumers didn't.
Well it was a,
it was an interesting tech,
like a moral tech debate that was going
on for awhile.
But the debate is lost.
I mean,
there was a,
um,
it's really interesting because there
was a guy who lived down the street from
me and he was a big time porn producer
and I actually knew him from my Jujitsu
class and he was a real high role in
sort of character.
Like he always had this beautiful
Mercedes Benz and he wore these really
big watches,
a lot of fancy clothes and he was just
making just tons of money and he had
this beautiful house and he was just
this baller character.
And then it all dried up,
dried up quick.
Yeah.
It went well.
Went into lost his house.
His house got repossessed.
Yeah.
And Fabian got so rich because of this,
because the money went from the orphans
pocket into Fabian's pocket.
Fabian got so rich that how's he rich
off of free streaming.
So the ads,
it was partly because of ads,
but partly because he brought up the
paid sites as well.
So you know,
because the paid sites were like
panicking because they were losing all
their money to piracy.
Bought up everything.
So we brought up the competition.
He bought it redtube youporn.
So he bought up all the competition to
Pornhub,
but he also bought loads of paid sites.
Be like playboy TV.
So your friend got so poor that his
house got repossessed.
Fabian got so rich that he installed in
his house and aquarium.
That was so big that it diver had to
come every week and dive in and clean
the coral reef.
You know,
you're doing well when you get your
diver.
That's weird.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you're right.
Porn people cared a lot,
but the outside world didn't care
because you know,
the outside world doesn't care where
music's getting pirated.
So they show this powder.
Carolyn,
it's porn.
Well,
they care a little bit about the music
thing,
but the porn thing got almost no
traction in when the porn industry is
essentially for the most part collapsed
or at least there was a massive amount
of loss.
There was no talk about like some sort
of a bail out or anything silly like
that.
I was like,
no,
that is gone.
Right.
Like many other industries were bailed
out.
And when you look at that are smaller,
right?
When you look at their headquarters up
in Montreal or the company that owned
pole,
now it's not poorly.
It's techie.
So your work.
And Fabian actually said to me,
quite tellingly,
he said yes.
He said it was amazing.
You wouldn't even know that we will have
input unless you went to the wrong
floor.
Now he seems like a guy who's well aware
of his crime.
Yeah,
I mean Fabian say if it wasn't me,
it,
it'd be somebody else.
What does that mean?
Um,
and it sounds like a good thing to say
after you kill somebody.
I did say,
um,
it's progress,
he'd call it progress,
but it's,
he's a criminal.
I mean it's essentially he's lucky that
he's dealing in pirated stuff,
right?
The one time Fabian got annoyed with me.
He was quite game like I wanted to,
I wanted to interview him and then I
wanted to travel to the valley to look
at the consequences and untraced
consequence through to consequence.
Like where would I end up if I just
because I think people don't think about
consequences on the Internet that much.
They want to just,
you know,
destroy somebody and then carry on with
their day.
So I wanted to tell a story about
consequences that the only time Fabian
got annoyed with me was when,
um,
either me or Mike Quasar director said
to him,
you know,
you uploaded pirated porn.
And he said,
no,
I didn't.
I've never uploaded pirated porn.
I offer a surface in which of the people
can upload pirated poured.
And if they tell us to take it down,
we'll take it down.
Which is they have to find it,
they have to find it,
and also there's so much fucking
freeport and I'm pulling that.
It's like cutting down the forest with a
butter knife.
It's impossible to.
You can,
you can say take down my partner Paul,
and they'll say okay.
So he found.
But then there's like a million other
people's report up there anyway yet.
So actually it's funny.
I don't,
by the way,
what I'm about to say shouldn't be
construed as me saying that I think that
Fabian is a psychopath because I don't.
But that thing about not taking
responsibility for your own actions.
I just remembered,
I wrote a book a few years ago about
psychopaths called the psychopath test
and a psychopathic trait is that like if
somebody killed somebody in a bar,
they would say,
well it's his fault for looking at me.
Funny.
So failure to accept responsibility for
our own actions is one of the 20 items
on the psychopath.
Jack,
do you think it is a psychopath or do
you think it's some sort of a con?
Convenient neglecting have certain
responsibility for what happened?
He did.
I don't think Fabian,
that was very much a tangential thing
because I don't think Fabian is a
psychopath at all,
but um,
I think that tech people have created a
sort of a moral bubble around
themselves.
I talked to the head of a porn hub's Mo
bow division.
So if you've ever watched his called
Brandon,
if you've ever watched a porn hub on
your mobile,
you have brandon to thank and I said to
brandon,
Brandon said like,
we never like 99 percent of pornhub
employees never set foot on a porn set.
And he said,
that's good because you know,
we're designing,
you know,
with search engine people were,
we don't want to say it would be a,
it would be sort of unpleasant to set
foot there would be sort of intimidating
and unpleasant.
And I said,
well maybe,
maybe it would've been good if more porn
hub people did set foot on porn sets
because you would be able to see the
negative consequences of your business
plan.
And Brendan went their livelihood,
which again is a very tacky thing to
say,
right?
Because it's all about,
it's all about progress,
their livelihood.
Yeah.
What does it mean by that?
Like,
okay,
now you want to talk about their
livelihood,
their livelihood people.
Yeah.
But I mean they're essentially like a
content provider that's not paying for
any content.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I just remembered a guy called David
lowery who's a WHO's a,
um,
uh,
he's,
he's interested in kind of piracy issue
in,
in music.
And he said when we look back on the
dystopian movies of the 19 thirties
where machines will take over like
metropolis or something like the moral
of the film that the climax of the film
is when the people,
the humans,
a defeat say,
you know,
I,
we're not going to live in a world run
by machines.
We're going to defeat the machines and
human morality or takeover.
But now that machines are ruling the
world,
instead of us defeating the machines,
we are adapting our morality to fit in
with the machines capability.
So because it is easy to pirate,
instead of saying let's not pirate,
we're just adapting a morality and
saying,
oh,
okay.
And we can watch pirated porn.
It's kind of,
yeah,
but it's not as simple as pirating
because pirating is what everybody does
on,
you know,
when,
when they're sharing it through message
boards or what have you,
that's sort of pirating right when
they're uploading it to these websites
and servers and stuff.
But what he's doing is massively
profiting off of other people's work.
It's a little bit of a more of a gray
area.
Yeah,
I'd say so.
He's not even gray,
Kinda dark when
he certainly profited hugely from other
people pirating their favorite porn
films onto his side because he had been
sued.
Uh,
he got into,
he got arrested for tax evasion.
Uh,
and that's how we got out of the
business eventually.
But I think that woke up,
that old got solved.
I'm not sure if he ever got sued because
if somebody says to him,
if somebody said to him,
like,
take down my,
my,
you know,
bad babysitters.
Volume two is mine.
I say that because I was actually on the
set of bad babysitters volume two.
Uh,
he'd say,
oh,
sure.
Yeah,
sorry,
of course.
And it would go down,
but then maybe somebody else will put it
up later that day or you know,
and it didn't matter because everything
else was very,
uh,
I tell you one amazing consequences of
all of this though.
Um,
so what I wanted to do in this order for
series a butterfly effect was to kind of
trace the consequences of this,
know what was the tornadoes that were
being created on one amazing consequence
is like Fabian surrounded himself with a
tech wizards.
Let people who knew how the Internet
worked,
including a lot of search engine people.
So instead of making porn films like
they made in the nineties,
um,
this porn director,
Mike Quasar said to me that the first
film he ever made back in the nineties
was called women of influence.
Now all the poem films have to be easily
searchable.
It's,
it's like a kind of arms race of search
engine optimization.
Like to get yourself up the google
rankings.
Uh,
so all the porn films in the valley
aren't called women of influence because
how do you search for that?
They're there.
They basically see what the most popular
search terms and then make films based
on that.
So Mike Quasar was telling me this on
the set of the film he was shooting that
day,
which was stepdaughter cheerleader orgy.
So I said,
so I said to just is just around the
corner.
So I said to Mike,
so there,
because I thought about light women of
influence versus stepdaughter
cheerleader orgy a look.
I haven't seen women of influence.
So for all I know the moral of women of
influences that women shouldn't have
influenced,
but my guess is that women have
influence is more kind of holistic
poured,
filmed and stepdaughter cheerleader
orgy.
So I said to Mike,
are there any people in the valley who
like,
can't get work because they're just not
a keyword?
And my one,
yeah,
like every asshole porn actress now
between the ages of 23 and 29 can't get
work because they're not a teen and
they're not a MILF.
They're like in this sort of fallow
periods between teen and MILF when
they're just attractive and just
attractive isn't a searchable term.
So if you're not a teen and you're not a
MILF,
if you're like a 26 year old adult film
actress,
you can't get work.
You just have to lie.
Well,
I said to Mike,
what do you do?
Do you just like sit there until you
become a MILF?
Become employable again.
The answers they have to find other ways
to make money.
So escorting is going through the roof
and in the Valley A.
Yeah,
because of the tech,
because people like Fabian because of
the tech takeover of porn.
Escorting is going through the roof.
But also another thing that's going
through the roof is this kind of weirdly
adorable world of bespoke porn.
Yeah.
And that's what the article will.
What was the,
uh,
publication who published that article
with The Guardian?
I did like a written version of one of
the episodes of the show.
I just stumbled upon it,
you know,
knowing that you going to be here.
I didn't even know you wrote it.
I was reading it and as I was reading I
was like,
oh,
John wrote,
this is what an amazing did you know
about this world?
Know on your ride in Portland,
here in the valley.
So yeah,
it's a pretty fascinating and explain
what it is.
Like people literally will request some
of the most bizarre things and these
people will make custom films based on
their weird kinks
just for them,
like a team of professional porn people
because the valley suffering so much
because of pornhub and so on.
We'll make an entire porn film just for
you
now.
How much does something like this cost?
Like say if you want to make a film
about girls when mutant Ninja turtle
outfits who kit guys in the balls,
like that's entirely possible,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Anything's possible.
But that sounds like something that
might actually sell at the yet.
Oh yeah.
They got like a couple of thousand
dollars.
That's it.
Yeah.
A couple grand.
Wow.
Uh,
I got so obsessed with the world of
bespoke porn because it was such a
fascinating window into people's inner
lives.
Like one of the first ones I saw was,
um,
was a condiments video,
ketchup and relish and stuff like that.
So it's a,
it's a woman sitting in a,
in a,
like a child's paddling pool and out of
shots.
What are the bespoke porn producers is
pouring industrial sized tubs of
condiments on her head,
like ketchup,
mustard and what's.
And the woman's like tried to,
you know,
she's being,
she's engaged.
So she's going,
oh,
it's so cold and slimy stuff.
Anyway,
the guy who commissioned this video,
the producers knew one thing about him.
He's a restauranteur who with continents
every day.
How weird and has to,
you know,
presumably for situations like that
happening in this restaurant.
So he just sits around thinking like as
customers sitting down a lot,
I like the score to her with some
mayonnaise.
Just lather up with cash or maybe it's
stress,
maybe it's like,
oh my God,
if this type of mayonnaise for
something,
we'll go,
fuck.
We get sued.
Yeah.
With doom.
Didn't like that'd be like cleaning
pill.
I,
maybe it's like maybe his release says
to do this.
Um,
wow.
Another one was a Norwegian man,
um,
has spent 40 years amassing of valuable
stamp collection on his bespoke porn
film.
Was descent his stamp collection to the
valley with three naked porn women would
destroy his stamp collection.
Whoa.
Yes.
Baker,
that's a steal from it.
I'm A.
Yeah.
How much does the stamp collection
worth?
Well,
lot.
Well it turns out because we managed to
track down stamps,
man,
and he talked to us off to a lot of
persuasion.
Uh,
and he's got 10 books of stamps.
Um,
once a year he sends one to accustom
woodsy.
So that's his thing.
Yeah,
it turns out it's because he grew up in
Iceland where stamp collecting was a
popular hobby at the time in like the
seventies and the eighties.
A stamp collecting was big.
So,
uh,
he became like an obsessive stamp
collector.
The stamp shop owners would say,
Oh,
if you buy this standards can be very
valuable in 20 years.
But then came the internet and it killed
off the stump.
Is it killed off stamp collecting as a
hoppy light?
Yeah.
Nerds apparently felt like other other
things to be interested in.
And you know,
the thrill of the chase just wasn't
there anymore.
Like you can easily pack.
Yeah.
So anyway,
so his stamps lost all of their value.
The stamp stores closed down,
that kind of collegial atmosphere of
fellow stamp collectors just vanished.
Uh,
he began to like,
you know,
regret his life choices of like spending
all that time and money collecting
stamps.
He began to feel depressed and isolated.
So he went to a CSI Chi atrust who told
them that stamp collecting is
ridiculous,
hoppy because it isolates him.
So now he pays porn people to destroy
his stamps.
The psychiatrist told them that a hobby
is ridiculous.
Yep.
According to him,
I'm not ever talked to the psychiatrist,
but according to him,
yeah,
he said that stamp collecting is a
ridiculous hobby.
That seems like a ridiculous thing for a
psychologist to say.
Sounds.
Yeah.
Bad Psychology.
Enjoys it.
Yeah.
If you're,
if you have all your ducks in a row and
everything is firing on all cylinders,
but you really truly enjoy stamps poos
who's to tell you there's something
wrong with that?
Well,
the only.
I mean,
one good thing that came out of it was,
um,
he really enriched the imaginations of
the people in the valley.
And also my imagination too,
I mean stamps man,
because all the custom producers talk,
you know,
and stamps man with such a mystery to
them all.
So you know,
so at least he destroys the stamps now
in a way that's beneficial to him.
Was so intriguing.
Yeah.
Isn't it amazing?
But it's all weird,
right?
Well it's also quite sad.
We,
I'm Dan and Rhiana and who made one of
the stamps videos called us just as we
were finishing our series and rhiannon
was in tears and they just had a request
and the request was for a guy,
a guy wanted a porn woman to sit cross
legged on the floor,
fully clothed and say into the camera,
you are loved.
Things may be bad now,
but they won't always be.
And suicide is not the answer.
Yeah.
So then they,
they felt,
fuck,
what do we do?
So they told him they'd make the video
for him and they could shoot it really
soon.
And he didn't,
he didn't respond.
So they made it anyway.
And we were there to record it.
And uh,
and it was very,
it made me realize just how kind of
delightful the bespoke porn world is
because they were so eager to,
to help this guy.
Did he jumps off?
We don't know.
They made the video for him.
Uh,
the woman,
the porn star,
Riley was saying into the camera,
you know,
I have thought about dying too,
but I came out of that hole,
you know,
and I came back stronger and now I can
see all the good in the world.
And Riley was crying and Rihanna and the
producer was crying and they sent the
video to the guy and we don't know,
you know,
it's interesting.
There's quite a few porn stars on
twitter that have,
you know,
are really like kind of motivational
twitter feeds.
Like they say nice things.
They say positive things.
So those,
they seem like healthy people and if you
separate the fact that they have sex on
film for a living,
take that out of the mix.
And what you have is like,
looks like your average person who's
trying to do better in this world and is
sharing positive things that they find.
It gives them inspiration and moves them
along in a certain way.
And,
but then you add the sex thing,
and for whatever reason we have this
weird hangup about sex.
It's because we're all fucked up.
I,
I talked to this girl called Dakota,
who was part of a radical honesty group
and radical honesty.
Have you come across rabbit?
No,
I don't think so.
You would love it.
I might be in one own and no,
it can I take a radical honest.
Okay.
Were the first time I ever heard about
radical honesty.
Um,
my friend's Starlee kine at the
podcaster who went on a radical honesty
group.
And one of the things you have to do run
a podcast.
Yeah.
She does a podcast called mystery show.
She used to be on this American life
anyway.
So she went to a radical honesty group.
Uh,
we have to be radically honest to each
other.
So at how it starts,
I've been touring as well.
It starts with everybody's sitting in a
circle and they have to confess to the
room a secret about themselves that
they've never told anyone.
So the one that started,
went to the first guy said,
uh,
my secret is that I haven't paid taxes
in 10 years.
And so everyone went,
oh,
and then the next guy said,
my secret is that I killed a man.
Yet he said I was in a truck.
I was driving a truck and I kicked the
passenger out of the truck and he fell
onto the road and he got run over and I
got away with it and nobody,
you know,
nobody knows that it was murder.
So then the next person in the circle,
when will my,
uh,
my secrets so disappointing compared to
that,
uh,
she said,
I suppose I can tell you that I have sex
with my cat.
So then the,
um,
murderer kind of put his hand up and
said,
disgusting.
Now,
so can I add somebody decent?
Could I add to my who should be sharing
with you,
saw the officer.
He said,
could I add something to my secret?
um,
I also have sex with my cat.
So anyway,
yeah,
one upper.
Yeah.
He had to,
like,
he had to be the best secret in the
room.
Here might be a bullshit artist.
It's possible.
That's part of the problem with those.
Yeah.
I should say,
by the way,
I met Brad Blanton,
the guy who runs these radical honesty
groups,
and I asked him whether Starley story
was true,
uh,
and he said yes.
That's the way she described that
circle.
This is what happened.
But,
so I was at this radical honesty group
in this church school in New Orleans,
and this girl called Dakota said that
her secret was that she was,
she's this young church girl.
She said her secret was actually watched
porn.
So I said,
what did you watch?
You Watch it on?
And she said,
hub,
of course,
this is how,
like every child in the world learns
about sex these days.
And I said,
did you ever get so into it that you
would like learn their names?
You'd say,
Oh,
there's James Dean.
And she said,
no,
no.
She kind of laughed.
And she said,
no,
I never learned their names.
It's like when you kill a deer,
you don't name it because then you can't
eat it.
So this is what the poor people are up
against.
Right.
It's this shame of,
of the,
of the viewer is like in,
in that hypocrisy lies,
exploitation,
which is why somebody like Fabian can
come in and get a $300,000,000
loan and take over porn.
It's because we don't want to think
about it because it makes us feel bad
about ourselves.
But that sort of thing.
But her,
her issue is like church going plus
female.
Whereas men,
they have very specific tastes and they
tend to gravitate towards very specific
porn stars.
Like one of the things that I've noticed
that really popular porn stars will have
like gigantic numbers on like social
media,
twitter or instagram,
like upwards of a million and maybe more
like.
And so they obviously have a following,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
you said that a lot of poem women on
twitter,
kind of a positive.
And the interventional messages,
one of the reasons why that is,
I met this,
um,
porn woman called macy may who was like
really depressed.
Another Fabian's consequences is that,
that kids grow up on,
on pornhub these days.
So there's no longer that kind of outlaw
status about coming to the valley to do
porn that they used to be in like the
eighties and nineties.
Now,
you know,
the valleys like flooded with women who,
who,
you know,
they turn 18,
they watch porn out,
they think that looks cool and then they
come to the valley and,
and a negative consequence to that is
that they get work for like a couple of
weeks and then,
you know,
there's loads more women off the bus and
so the producers don't need to employ
them anymore.
So there's a massive turnaround to get
work for a few weeks and then it's over.
So I met this woman called macy May,
who was in that funk lack.
She came in May throughout May.
She was working,
I met her in July and the worker just
dried up,
uh,
and she,
she was like venting on twitter and,
but then she stopped venting and then
all of her tweets were like,
I'm so happy.
It's such a beautiful day.
And I said,
why did you stop venting on twitter?
And she said,
well,
a bunch of porn producers told me it
looked bad for my brand.
Um,
that,
you know,
they don't,
they don't want us sort of miserable
poor person saying I'm not getting work
today.
They want to pull person who says,
here's a picture of my butt.
Uh,
and isn't that unhealthy right there?
This is what we've turn twitter into.
We've turned into this thing where we're
not allowed to be ourselves or to tell
the truth about ourselves.
Well,
in this particular example maybe,
but I mean,
I think it's an inherently,
for whatever reason,
in,
in my estimation and many others,
a depressing business.
Yeah.
And I don't know why.
I mean,
for a lot of people,
the idea of young girl going into porn
is depressing.
You know,
like I have daughters.
Your idea of my daughter's going into
porn is very depressing.
No,
but I've met porn stars and seem nice.
They seem happy.
So I mean,
but why is it that it's.
Everybody wants to have sex,
but if you have sex on film.
Yeah.
And everybody gets to wash the shame.
It's weird.
It's a weird side effect of our
civilizations.
The shame coming in from,
from the outside looking in.
There's no shame when I was on the set
of stepdaughter cheerleader orgy,
which was quite close to where we are
now,
probably like a mile away from here,
but up in the hills and um,
it was a kind of familial bubble.
Like everyone must be nice to each other
and was happy.
But Mike,
the director needed to get an
establishing shots if the cheerleaders
arriving home from cheerleader practice.
So we went outside.
They were wearing their cheerleader
outfits and some teenagers had caught
onto what was happening at a porn film
was being shot,
like up on a nearby hill.
And they were like cat calling and
hissing and sort of mocking these girls.
And for the first time,
not just the girls,
but the camera man,
the director,
everybody suddenly felt like self
conscious and the girls were like,
you know,
sort of try to put guys.
So until the mocking outside is came
along,
it was healthy and shame free.
But as soon as an outsider started
hissing at them,
it became shameful.
And I think that's,
that's,
that's poor.
And for you,
like most of the problems that poor
people face,
a stigma from the outside,
not from the community itself,
which tends to be quite respectful.
And the people that were mocking them,
first of all,
they're young teenagers and second of
all they're probably thinking of it in
terms of like,
almost like their online.
Yeah.
I mean like one of the things about
online is there's no consequences for
what you're saying.
And then people have no problem shitting
on people.
We couldn't see them.
We could only hear them.
I was looking,
looking up and I couldn't say them
because they were up on like a rich
about the house.
Uh,
yes.
So just almost like being anonymous.
Yeah.
I mean,
anonymous people online,
it's,
the behavior is very bizarre because
like sometimes I'll see people's
comments,
whether it's to me or to somebody else
and they're so fucking vicious and nasty
over nothing over,
nothing over nothing.
Yeah.
You know,
someone's movie that they did or some
album that they did or whatever it was.
And she,
uh,
shitting all over every aspect of their
purse just almost,
just to try to get them to hurt the way
they're hurting,
you know,
that's almost what it seems like.
It's like you're just like super angry,
bitter person.
It's just life is just throwing rocks at
them everywhere they go and every chance
they get throw rock back.
They do.
Yeah.
That,
that random even song.
I,
I just want you to hit like I do.
Yeah,
I'd say there's certainly an element to
that.
There's also an element of what the
right call.
What was that phrase that the use all
the time,
a virtue signaling,
which I don't like using that phrase
because it's so been kind of adopted by
this sort of,
you know,
white nationalists,
but that's.
But it exists actually.
Signaling is absolutely real.
I see it all the time.
I say it all the time.
It's usually like really,
really weak men know,
like trying really hard to court the
favor of women and they're not
attractive and they're not desirable.
And so they try really hard to be
allies.
And the last time I was here I,
I just don't feel that as it was out of
my public shaming book coming out.
Oh yeah.
And like a sort of small group of people
decided to sort of try this group.
Yeah.
Wrong thing.
You were guilty of wrong thing.
Yeah.
I just read a story this morning in
voucher about the young adult world
where this book came out called,
um,
what's it called?
Like the light.
Let me see if I can find it.
Um,
called the black witch and it said it's
a liberal book as a young adult book
that's a liberal book is a progressive
book,
but it contains a racist characters.
So a blogger took some of the quotes
that the racist characters set in the
book.
This voucher article quote certainly in
took them out of context,
page one,
six three.
The celts are not a pure race like us.
They're more accepting of into marriage
and because of this they're hopelessly
mixed.
So that's a quote from the book.
And then the blog wrote underneath.
Yes.
You read that with your own two eyes.
This is one of the times my jaw drops in
horror and I had to walk away from this
book.
So then how noble.
So then like hundreds and hundreds of
people like pounding on the book and
then Kirk gave this book or a good
review.
And then people pounding on circus
circus.
Circus is like this industry is that
when you write a book,
one of the first review to get us from
Kirkus.
It's like it's an industrial,
that word K I r,
K u s.
okay.
And if you get like a start because she
feels like a big deal.
And um,
so they piled in on curriculum for
giving it a good review.
But I noticed two things happened as
result of this.
One was actually,
it didn't seem to affect the book's
success.
Uh,
the book is doing well,
like on Amazon and people actually read
the book,
I'm offended by it and the same thing
happened with my book.
So you've been publicly shamed,
like the cat of people trying to turn
against the book.
It didn't.
Well,
the numbers are so small numbers of
twats that are actually out there
beating the bushes for this stuff.
When you're talking about,
you know,
2000 people or whatever,
or 100 maybe even very vocal and if
there's anyone particularly upset at
you,
it might just be there's,
there's many instances where people were
attacked by one person and that person
assumes multiple identities online,
an out of body.
Mine was dealing with someone who was
doing that.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's real common.
Like they're just,
for whatever reason,
just single you out.
Or maybe you wrote something that you
know,
they found personally offensive or.
But the thing that drives me crazy about
that,
about this taking out of context,
this character who's a racist character
is we were talking about fiction and
fiction.
If you can't portray realistic humans
mean there are racist,
but how come you're allowed to make a
fictional character about a murderer or
about,
you know,
some sort of a Nazi type character or
something along those lines.
Like how come that's okay.
I mean these are like,
you know,
these are kind of young kids because
this is the why a world and I,
I,
you know,
why a young adult type of publishing and
they're not thinking it through.
They're there,
they're not thinking,
they're just seeing an opportunity to be
outraged.
You know,
that,
you know the expression recreational
outrage.
Yeah.
And so,
but the other thing that happened as a
result of their.
So the book itself apparently isn't
being particularly negatively affected,
even though the,
the outrage was,
was huge.
Probably helps it possibly.
But I'm the journalists from this
vulture article interview publishers who
basically a stagnant.
We're telling our authors to get as
having a chilling effect on,
on novels.
It's like,
don't put in like if,
if the authors white don't try and put
in a person of color as a cat and it's
just,
it's not worth it,
you know,
just don't do it.
So actually these new roles,
a new roles a few years,
I just wrote this,
um,
I've been writing movies lately and,
and um,
and I always try and put in characters
of color and because I think,
okay,
you know,
maybe a director will kind of ignore it,
but if I put that into a screenplay,
then there's a good chance that a person
of color is going to get offered,
you know,
a role,
but now suddenly I'm being told like,
that's not,
that's not good.
I shouldn't do that.
Will you be told you're being told you
shouldn't do that because you need to
stay in your lane?
Yeah.
What?
I'm not been told it,
but I'm reading these articles where I
read that novelists of being told this
is a different situation.
You're not talking about an offensive
character.
You should probably clarify that.
Oh yeah,
no,
of course.
No.
Well,
you're talking about is someone's
telling you not to do or maybe you
shouldn't do a person of color in your
screenplay because that's not your
place.
Yeah,
right.
It's been told according to this
voucher,
Roscoe,
that everyone today route isn't being
told not to do it,
so.
No,
no,
of course not.
Like that's a different thing.
It could easily be misconstrued.
I didn't want to let anybody take you
out of context there.
Right?
Yeah,
no,
of course.
And that feels like have a new role.
It is,
yeah.
Well it's just,
again,
it's,
it's just the left is turning on itself.
I mean there are people that are turning
on them so there you cannot be
progressive enough.
There was no one out there that's
progressive enough and so there's always
gonna be someone to find some fault in
something that you do,
particularly if you're doing fiction
that portrays a realistic scenarios that
could easily exist in any city,
in any,
you know,
civilization on earth.
Yeah.
And I noticed when,
when,
you know,
because I was covering all of this for a
couple of years,
months writing,
so you've been publicly shamed and I,
and I noticed that every time somebody
like justine sacco got kinda got,
got on the Internet,
um,
Breitbart and info wars,
Molly Annapolis,
Paul Joseph Watson,
Alex Jones,
you know,
they would propagandize the hell out of
this stuff.
And this was in the runup to trump
getting elected.
And I can't help thinking that the left
eating itself is part of the reason why
we've got trump now really fucked up for
sure.
They became unreasonable when there's a
meme that's going out there that I've
seen on many,
many different places on instagram and
twitter and stuff.
It says this kind of shit is why I got
elected.
And it's trump like pointing at the
camera.
I think it's true.
It's 100 percent true.
People were fed up,
they're fed up and they,
you know,
they didn't realize what the
consequences are.
You know,
what's really fascinating is I saw this
article today where it was talking about
America was on cnn about Americans,
like in general,
like everyone pulled,
does not like the fact that trump tweets
or some crazy number people to think
that he should stop tweeting.
But one of the things that got him
elected is the fact that he tweets said
people enjoyed it.
Like,
here's a guy who fighting back and he's,
he's not,
he's not scared to hit back with
personal insults.
And like we'd never seen that before
from someone running for president.
Like this was stunning.
Yeah.
You know,
but then he became president.
Everybody's like,
well,
he'll surely let that go once he's in
the office because that's not
presidential.
But he used the expression,
you know,
I,
I forget the expression,
but something like,
it's modern presidential.
Yeah.
I remember the very first book I ever
did for seed been purposely saying there
was this woman in front row,
uh,
this kind of elderly lady.
This was the book shop Santa Cruz.
And she was like pointedly shaking her
head and disagreements with everything
that I was saying.
And then when it came to the q and a,
I said,
I haven't got any questions that she
went.
She said,
uh,
I said,
okay.
I just said if you play,
she said,
if you play with the twitter toy that
it's your fault if you get what I'm,
what I said to him was like,
you know,
it's influences beyond twitter.
Twitter is,
twitter is infecting the culture and
it's an infected everything.
What the Gan on twitter,
new type of discourse and the new way of
seeing each other infected politics,
culture,
the mainstream media.
It's affected everything in the same way
that I wonder where the Fabian fs sort
of feels a bit guilty about some of the
consequences of his business plan.
I wonder whether some of the,
uh,
twitter executives ever feel guilty
about what they've done.
Well,
they certainly
feel like they have some sort of
responsibility,
which is why their silencing certain
people.
And I don't know if shadow banning is
real,
but there's,
there's all this talk of people being
shadow band and then a lot of people
have had their accounts suspended.
Yeah.
I said they got doing a bit of stuff
now.
I was a member,
um,
mechanism.
They,
uh,
Westboro Baptist Church Mckee who's a
friend of mine and she,
Oh,
she came on your show.
She was amazing.
She's so great.
Fascinating that someone who came from
such a horrible regressive environment
became this fascinating,
really intelligent,
really well-spoken,
sensitive person.
And I think Meghan would say if she was
sitting there because I kind of said
that at one time and she said it sort of
goes to show that,
you know,
full,
that sort of hateful beliefs.
My parents were good parents,
like they gave me this positive stuff as
well as the nicotine.
Wow.
That amazing.
She can't even talk to them anymore.
Yeah.
But they won't talk to her.
Talk to her.
I think she went up to them at a,
a picture of David Bowie's memorials.
I,
they wouldn't talk.
They wouldn't look her in the eye.
And anyway,
she was on the phone to twitter one time
she told me,
uh,
because they love it.
I mean,
twitter love that because she hadn't,
she sort of got talked into liberals on
twitter and that's,
that's what persuaded or perhaps if the
Westboro Baptist church.
So for twitter,
that's like the best story in the world.
So she was talking to Theresa,
she told me and they wanted her to do a
talk and she said,
Oh,
you should do a talk as well.
Jon Ronson.
And she said,
she said twitter went quiet and phone.
So they're upset at you and they're
upset.
It may for basically pointing out what,
uh,
you know,
how will total is crawling towards the
gun on twitter,
but you know,
that it's not all people.
What you're see,
you're pointing out some of the issues
that many other people have seen.
This is not what you don't think.
What you're saying is controversial at
all.
You're just astute.
I don't think so that,
that story about,
about justine sacco a few years ago and
about how,
you know,
the woman who tweeted going to Africa,
hope I don't get aids,
just kidding.
I'm white.
And then when she was pregnant,
when she was asleep on the plane,
you know,
thinking she'd made a smart cut of south
park joke around privilege,
like everyone united to choose,
fired,
fired by the time she landed.
Yeah.
And you know,
um,
everyone from like misogynistic troves
through to social justice people all
united to destroy this urban,
you know,
she upset everyone for um,
and uh,
yeah,
so that,
I think that story became pretty
powerful at the time.
And I think it probably back to
twitter's business for a while.
People got too scared to go into it.
So I think that's a drop their business
off at all.
I think it did.
I think,
I think people started to think that it
may have recovered now,
but I think people started to think,
fuck,
if twitter is not fun,
you know,
what's,
what's the point of the Justine Sacco
one racist joke that she got fired for,
you think that really had an overall
effect on twitter use?
Well,
what happened was I,
my book got extracted in the New York
Times did,
was that story.
And that story kind of went crazy viral.
Um,
it really spoke,
it kind of spoke to people.
It's like Duh,
like deep fears,
that story.
Well,
deep fears.
They might get drunk and pop a Xanax and
say something really stupid.
Did the same shit,
wake up in Africa fired.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I think that that kind of public
effected twitter,
I think it did.
I think they need to relax.
I think all that stuff just makes people
interested and then it makes more people
sign up and I just,
I don't know,
boy,
I don't see that at all.
If they were upset at you over that,
that's pretty preposterous.
I wonder,
I've given.
I gave talks at facebook and Google,
but they won't give you a talk going on,
but I'm curious.
I'm curious for their orwellian council
and maybe they'll go over every word
you're about to say.
Allow what is their trust and verify
council,
what the fuck is that called?
Where they have all,
they have some people on that are that
are ridiculous.
Social Justice Warriors,
proven attention whores.
People that are dishonest.
They're just not,
they're not honest people and they're a
part of this whole thing where their
business is getting attention and being
a victim and and exploring it to the nth
degree.
I mean,
that's,
that's a bunch of people that are on
that thing.
That's what they do.
I do think like if you're gonna address
harassment on social media,
you have to accept that it comes from
both sides and the right to the left.
It comes from the left to the right.
It comes to misogynists feminists that
comes from feminist.
You also have to define what is
harassment and what is criticism.
Now,
if you have ideas in the open
marketplace of ideas and you have ideas
that people think are profoundly
ridiculous,
they're allowed to mock your ideas.
That is not harassment.
I just think that that is someone
shitting on you and you put yourself out
there.
I mean,
especially someone whose hook.
You're not.
These people,
a lot of them,
they're not singers,
they're not authors,
they're not musicians,
they're not comics.
They're not.
They're not producing anything other
than their words.
Right?
So if someone doesn't like your words
and they shit on your words like that,
what else do you expect?
Yeah,
I noticed that there was some kind of
gaslighting going on on the left,
like,
like everyone would agree that sort of
world that I come from,
not the Guardian and the left La.
Everyone would agree that if a gun of
Bissell actionists sort of gang up on a
particular feminist writer and basically
harassed until she goes flying every new
case,
that's,
that's bad and is bad.
It is yet.
Um,
but when the mirror image of that is
happening,
people pretended as if people just
pretend it's not happening.
Right?
When someone goes after someone on the
right,
even if it's a woman like,
you know,
a perfect example of that was no
feminist stood up to defend Sarah
Pailin.
Like there's no one.
I mean you never heard that when Bill
Maher was calling her a cunt and all
these different people were mocking her
and no one was stepping up and saying,
hey,
that's a woman that's a mother.
You know,
it's someone's,
someone's mom,
like leave her alone.
Have some respect for women if you're a
woman and you're a conservative,
like you might as well be a monster man.
That was,
there was undoubtedly sort of cognitive
dissonance,
like
when somebody's being harassed,
they don't want to then see themselves
as,
as doing the same thing to a group of
people that they don't like.
Well,
it's very easy to come to think of
someone who is opposed to your point of
view or thinks of things completely
different as another.
You don't even think of them as a
person.
I noticed that happened to me,
you know,
I wanted to
said that they wanted to run a series of
articles about,
um,
about bullying on the Internet and
wanted me to like,
you know,
contribute to the series a.
and they said they wanted it to all be
about how women are being bullied by
men.
And I said,
um,
you know,
I have no doubt that,
that happens a lot and it's presumably
disproportionate.
Like women are bullied by men more than
other groups have bullied.
You know,
that could well be true,
but if the series of article is only
about women being bullied by Merlin,
legitimize a certain types of bullying,
like when the left pile in on somebody
like just in soccer,
it's going to legitimize,
you know,
what if it's that partial is going to
legitimize certain types of bullying.
And the editor,
when I said that to her,
kind of rolled her eyes as if to say,
well,
you would think that erm,
yeah,
but you know,
it's true,
it's true.
And,
and you know,
the problem's not going to go until we.
Yeah,
they're hypocrites.
I mean that's essentially what's going
on.
So people don't want to be nice.
They,
they think that there's power and
shaming and they think.
I mean I've,
I've had multiple conversations with
people online that think there is good
in shaming people.
I'm like,
what you saying that because you're
hiding behind a keyboard and it's a free
shot,
but if you had to sit down with that
person in front of them and talk to them
face to face and feel the social
consequences.
Right.
It reminds me actually remember I was
telling you about what are the
consequences that I look at in the best
of fly effect about the tech takeover of
port is that if you're a 25 year old
adult actress,
you can't get work now because you're in
this sort of hinterland between teen and
MILF.
And I kept that.
That's not just pawn,
that's the Internet.
Like on social media,
you know,
if you're,
if you're kind of loud,
aggressively authoritarian person on the
left or the loud aggressively
authoritarian person on the right,
you like the teen or the MILF like those
of us in the middle of these people who
are more interested in people talking to
each other and,
and they don't,
we don't want to like scream.
We want to listen to understand.
We like the 25 year old adult film
actress at work.
Well,
people don't like nuanced point of view
and they also like people that are
willing
to talk to anybody.
You know?
I've had so many people call me some
sort of a right wing monster and I'm
like,
well,
let's go over what makes a right wing
monster.
W,
w what is right wing.
I support gay marriage support.
Universal health care.
I'm absolutely in favor.
If it could work,
I don't know if it would work of a
universal basic income.
Where does it,
where do I become right wing?
Like what?
Where does it go?
I'm anti war.
Like where do I become right when?
Well,
I don't think I can in politics as input
on everything now has to be kind of
keywords that Chabot,
so everybody has to fall into some sort
of nation and if you're not doing it
yourself,
then someone else is gonna do it for
you.
Yeah,
but even when you're saying that like
you don't,
that's not real.
Like you don't have to.
You don't have to fall into those
categories.
It's just be easier for people to
categorize you.
If you did fall into those categories.
I'm sure I have some points of view that
people would consider a conservative and
I have many more points of view that
most people would consider to be
liberal,
but it's very convenient,
especially when you look like me and I
looked like a meathead is easy to say
that I'm some meathead conservative or
right wing or something along those
lines,
but I'm way more likely to vote for
someone on the left than I am for
someone on the right because I think the
people on the right,
jen in general are more suppressive.
Especially socially and culturally and I
think that's where the real issues.
Like when you look at like Obama did.
Yeah,
on the right.
When you look at what Obama did in
office in terms of like what he did as
far as drones,
a freedom of the press and going on
after whistle blowers and got a lot of.
That was very right.
Very right wing.
If you looked at in terms of like an
actual real consequences of him being
the president,
a lot of it was very right wing,
but when you look at in terms of like
support for gay marriage and you know,
in passing the affordable care act and
all these,
there's a lot of that stuff was very
left wing.
Now I don't know if the affordable care
act was good because a lot of small
businesses,
the small doctors with small offices
hated it and thought it was absolutely
horrible and it killed their business.
I don't know who's right about that
because I don't.
Obviously I don't have to deal with
that.
It's a controversial subject,
but the idea behind it I liked.
I liked the idea that we would have some
sort of universal healthcare because I
think the idea of someone being too poor
to get healthcare in this incredible
country,
like if we're going to pay for our taxes
are going to go to anything.
God Damn doesn't.
It shouldn't go to caring for our
neighbors and our,
our fellow humans.
Like that seems to me to be a no
brainer.
Yeah,
and that's probably a pretty left wing
idea why I got a ton of those,
but,
but it's easy to call me a right winger
for whatever reason.
I find that fascinating that people do
not like us a nuanced approach or not.
Not only that,
it's not that they don't like it is that
they find it extremely easy to
categorize
you and so we're sort of a,
a negative caricature.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I've got a question.
I'm just like totally change the subject
for a second.
Uh,
we have Alex Jones a common cause I,
years ago snuck into Bohemian Grove with
Alec and weird.
It was that,
that was like the one he didn't like the
late nineties,
early 2019.
You are with them on that.
That's right.
Yeah,
we talked about that the last time.
Yeah.
Um,
but I,
I,
since I saw you last,
I rekindled my relationship with Alex as
a means of trying to get inside the
trump world didn't go,
didn't go great.
It didn't go well.
What happened that?
Well,
what I think I heard Alex a little bit,
although would you do.
I basically set allocation.
Have political sway you told him that.
What?
I wrote it in a story about him.
I went to the RNC and I sort of,
you know,
got back in with Alex and spent a little
bit of time hanging around with him and
Roger Stone and so on and got really
interested in the kind of dynamics of
how Alex and trevor communicate to each
other,
but I'm wondering if you've seen Alex
more recently than I have been my
friends since 1998.
Yeah.
I was at his custody trial not long ago.
And you were brought up by my shirt.
He was smoking pot.
Just testing it.
George Soros makes the weeds stronger.
That's very steady.
He said that in this custody trial.
That's exactly what he said.
He said he tests it once a year just to.
Because he's weird because he's always
here when that happened.
I mean,
come on man.
What's really funny is we drank whiskey
on the show too and no one gives a shit
about that.
It's way more destructive.
It's the pot.
Whatever it is.
Self reflective.
Yeah.
Paranoia.
Inducing marijuana.
It's a real problem,
but I,
I now wonder,
so he says that trump called him just
after the election,
just thank him and I'm inclined to
believe that's true because I don't
think that's the kind of thing that Alex
would lie about,
but have you got any of you come to any
conclusion about whether there is a
connection between Alex and trump now?
Because I'm beginning to think maybe
there just isn't anymore,
but I could be wrong.
I've got a good question.
I don't know.
I mean,
first of all,
I don't see how trump can have a
connection with that many people.
I feel like the job of being the
president has got to be so insanely
demanding.
The idea that he likes.
He's taken a few moments out of his day.
He's got his feet up on the chair with a
laptop and he's on infowars.com.
I was like,
God damn.
I got to call it Alex and find out what
the fuck's going on with this child
slavery thing on Mars.
You know where the slaves tell me where
we're on Mars.
I think it benefits everyone to think
that it's because it makes,
it makes trump look bad,
so it benefits people on the left
descending that Alex is a,
is connected to trump.
It kind of benefits Alex.
I think for people to think it too,
because grand dies is,
it helps him in a way.
I mean it's like the people that.
There's a bunch of people that enjoy
Alex,
right?
So some of them enjoy it for the
theater.
There's a theater element of it all,
you know,
I mean,
and it's all doom and gloom and.
Yeah.
And then some of it,
some people enjoy because like Bohemian
grove occasionally he's correct.
Like Bohemian Grove was a real mind
fuck.
And you see all these super rich people
wearing robes in effigy.
Yeah.
I was in the crowd with all the old men
of wealth in Dallas to freak you out.
And soon as people,
one thing freaked me out.
I'm like,
Alex came out of our Bohemian Grove
Knight with a,
with varying interpretation of your
interpretation.
My interpretation is basically with,
with one caveat caveat there,
my interpretation was that it's just
like fucking skull and bones.
So those were all creepy,
right?
Yeah.
And they want to devastate that just
seem to be amongst the American ruling
elites,
that does seem to be a proclivity for
ritual.
Um,
maybe,
uh,
maybe monks of British elites as well.
I'm not sure about that.
That's in itself psychologically
interesting.
Think secrets too.
Right?
So it's like,
why?
So that is interesting.
Why even if the ritual at Bohemian
Grove,
I,
you know,
and I would contend that country to alex
implied they weren't actually
sacrificing a child.
No,
he didn't say they were sacrificing your
chart at some point.
And then this video.
Yeah,
it couldn't be real,
be real.
He probably was so jazzed up,
but they were actually dressed up like
monks.
He with the hoods and they have the mall
of the,
our God,
when he was actually there,
I mean that probably ramped up his love
of conspiracy a good solid three or 400
percent.
It was hilarious because you know,
we went in separately to to,
because Alex got it into his head that
maybe I was part of the Bohemian Grove
deep deep inside that I was like
learning events seven.
He would be the ones,
so he went in separately to be,
he won't and fire the undergrowth and I
went up to the drive in the driveway.
I gave the security guy to cut a viral,
the world wave and then we went in
there.
Her Toyota do.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Guys,
so often the case.
Yeah.
So the White House and then we saw Alex
and Mike Hanson who was his producer at
the time,
walking like towards this and I was with
this local lawyer who would,
who would we talked up with?
And I was like,
um,
Hey Alex,
Mike,
how you doing?
They were like,
keep walking as cameras and the chase.
This owl was everywhere.
And then there's.
Yes,
because we felt like the hours were
cameras.
They got it into their heads that the
owls at Bohemian Grove,
the,
our motifs that Bohemian Grove a was
indicative of the fact that it was like
moloch the owl God,
uh,
and it was like some sort of satanic.
But actually I would say that the reason
why there's all those hours because I
saw like stuffed owls and display
cabinets and so on.
But I think it's like,
I think it's an owl sanctuary.
So,
but anyway,
but I want to put all this stuff done.
I mean,
I presume it died of natural causes.
Shit.
He fucking sanctuary if they kill it and
then stuff it.
So it's sorta like a norman bates mom
and psycho stuff.
But what was odd that night was one
thing that the artist moment,
and this is where I will,
this is where my memory of the night
does tally with Alex's,
is that for whatever reason the people
in the crowd were really into this,
this ceremony.
There was a sort of.
They were really fired up by it.
Let say I remember this old guy walked
up to me before it started and you first
timer and I went,
yeah,
I do.
Oh,
you got to love it.
You're gonna.
Love it.
Burn him,
burn him or something,
something along those lines.
Uh,
and,
and it did make me think la.
And then I looked behind and there was
alex and Mike,
why died looking like they will ruin,
know the belly of the beast.
And then there's all these old preppy
men.
Why died?
Did they were really into it too.
I felt like the only sane person in the
entire redwood forest,
I was like,
the only person who's thinking this is
fucking ridiculous.
It is ridiculous.
But,
but they were into it.
It was that moment.
It was that moment of revelation
actually,
that then led me to write the book that
I wrote after that book,
which was the minister at goats,
which was about,
you know,
um,
soldiers tried to kill goats just by
staring at them because I remember like,
um,
I remember thinking I was actually,
I was in Belfast,
I was giving a talk about my book then,
which is where we talk about all of that
stuff.
And it simply said,
okay,
so I know what you think of it.
This woman in the audience said,
I know what you think,
I know you think this is ridiculous and
I know that Alex Jones thinks it's evil,
but what about the people in the crowd?
What were they thinking about it?
And I thought that's a really good
question.
So that's what led me to write a book
about like a rational thoughts in
powerful places,
which is what led me to adminster guts.
No,
when you,
when you're there and you see that there
really is a giant stone owl and they
really do have this bundle of sticks and
they're burning and everyone really is
wearing these robes.
Like,
I mean you had a part of you how to be
like,
how many of these fucking things are
going on that we have an infiltrated?
Well that's true that there's a,
there's a photo over there.
This is real.
I mean they really do have a giant owl
and they really do burn some sort of a
sacrifice in front of this owl and
there's a speakers that are at one
point,
this is a lesser
documented part of the ritual.
At one point there's a guy in leaf
covered later hosan appears in like a
stage cutouts of the redwood tree and
start singing this kind of allergy to
nature.
Like,
oh,
trees.
So leaves.
So that's how it starts.
That's before the men in robes.
Turnip.
So it's like some weird pagan nature
leach covered later.
Hose and Joe,
how much would you give to be in one of
those skull on bonds meetings?
See if they actually like film each
other's sucking Derek's or something
there.
There's something that goes on where
they have like something over those
guys.
Supposedly that's like the the
conspiracy theories.
That's it makes them engage in gay sex.
I do believe these things happen for a
reason.
Like you know it's going to.
Bones exists for a reason because they
have something over you.
It could be that or it could be just
this weird sense,
this weird sort of psychological need
that people like Ivy League people feel
they need to like have a sense of
superiority and we're meant to do that
is to kind of create these secret
rituals to give them a sense of like,
you know,
grand juror over the people if that's
possible.
Now a guy like Alex Jones stumbles upon
something like that or infiltrates it
and find out it is real.
I mean that is just a fine to such a and
enormous,
enormous level.
Yeah.
But Alex,
but here's my,
my truck with Alex and all of this is
that it wasn't like the Alex.
all of their fucking crazy shit that we
saw that night wasn't enough lucky hat
to like turn it up to 11 of course.
Yeah,
and imply that weird possibly witnessed
an actual human sacrifice and of course,
but that standard,
that standard Alex Jones one-on-one.
But it shouldn't be.
It shouldn't be.
But I mean,
I mean think about all of the
exaggerations exaggerations that take
place in the media,
whether it's on the left or the right.
There's a ramp and exaggerations.
Well,
it's funny you should say that.
So did you watch Alex being interviewed
by Meghan Kelly?
Yeah.
Well that may be like,
you know,
they phoned me a couple of days before
the broadcast.
Meghan Kelly's people because they were
panicking to remember there was like a
lot of criticism they were getting for,
for having a on in the first place.
So they called me up and they basically
wanted me to give them as much evidence
as I could prove that Alex and trump
were aligned and they will talk to each
other and so on.
Called you.
Why?
Because you went to Bohemian grow with
them.
I went to go pee,
then I also put out this little kindle
single last summer called the elephant
in the room in which I'm trying to
trace,
like the relationship between Alex and
trump didn't fire up street.
It's kind of in this interesting stuff.
But um,
so I answered the questions as best as I
could,
but I don't know that much about exactly
how often trumping alex talk to each
other,
either had it or didn't really that
interested in it as odd as it is.
Like I have a very fucked up
relationship with Alex in,
in that and he's actually my friend and
so when I see him it's like,
what's up
man?
What are you doing?
I give him a hug and people go,
oh,
he's a monster or how can you be friends
with them and this and that.
And like,
I dunno,
I just base it on my interactions with
them.
And what does he say?
Fucked up things.
Yeah.
The most disturbing thing that I didn't
even know when he did the podcast,
I didn't know that he was sandy hook
denier.
Right.
So apparently he's backed off that since
being confronted by the facts and,
and there was a horrible article that I
read about a father who was actually a
conspiracy theorist until his son was
killed in Sandy Hook and then he got
death threats for lying and Zoom Info
wars and that was so just so just so
sad.
Yeah.
That's just so people look for fucking
conspiracies and everything and I don't
know what it is.
I have friends that have this issue.
I don't understand it.
Things that could be easily explained.
They look for a conspiracy and it
happens in the news.
There's gotta be a different story.
Like sometimes shit just happens and
when that shit happens,
the news has a story.
It doesn't always have to be some sort
of nefarious plot,
but these people also think that the
government is filled with idiots.
Boy,
I'm sorry you can't have it both ways.
You can't have a bunch of incompetent
fuck heads who pull off the perfect fake
world where everything you see is some
sort of an elaborate played out scheme
in order to manipulate you and d they're
buying this are voting for that.
Like there's a weird inclination that
people have to not just,
not just some conspiracy theories but
almost everything to think everything
and some part of some crazy plot.
I'm not sure I understand it.
What you said about biases and untruths,
like across the media on the left,
I'm reminded to be if the Meghan Kelly
thing,
so they phoned me up obviously in a bit
of a panic because they would get
getting so much criticism and then they
react to the show like frantically,
just before,
wherever he edited it.
What did they change?
Well,
I don't know,
but what I do know is like you.
I saw the final product and the final
product was basically Meghan Kelly
looking incredibly poised,
saying you'll rung Alex,
you'll run about this,
and then it would cut out.
It's good,
but I didn't recover to Meghan so.
Oh they did.
Was Alex that is most sweaty stuttery
and then Meghan Kelly at her most poised
to.
Perfect.
What did you see or hear?
The Alex Jones,
uh,
audio,
the leaked audio that he released?
Yes.
Were they were sort of buttering him up
and conning him?
Yeah,
he was saying personally,
I was saying I don't,
I'm not here to make a hit piece.
I just want to know the real you.
And almost although they did get it so
I,
I wouldn't do what the original program
would have been like because they felt
forced to buy him yet.
Well,
they felt forced by like the people
pushing back against them doing it.
Him A to then put out this Shitty,
you know,
10 minutes.
Basically it was in Meghan Kelly's
corner.
I would have told her,
first of all,
don't ever go to NBC.
Listen,
here's the deal like you,
you made your bones as an ice princess
on this conservative network and do you
think they're just going to accept you
at NBC?
People are going to resent you.
They're going to hate you.
Like you're the lady that chastise
people for saying that Santa Claus
potentially wasn't white.
Remember that?
I don't remember that.
Oh my God.
It was some thing where they were saying
there,
there was people talking about Santa
Claus being black and I'll never forget
it because she was on tv going,
you know Santa Claus is white.
Like then I'm like,
what the fuck the fuck are you talking
about?
Santa Claus isn't real.
You crazy bitch.
You can't say Santa Claus is white more
than you could say cat in the hat is
red.
They're not real things know.
You can decide that.
You know like the cat in the hat in the
book is always white.
Okay.
Yeah,
you're right.
Good point.
But it is he black,
white.
What does the cat in the hat?
He's got a hat is red and white.
What color is he though?
I think he's black.
Right?
Izzy?
Okay.
All right.
It's not important,
but what's important is that like her
whole thing was being a spokesperson.
This ultra hot spokesperson for the
conservative movement,
but also being someone who's ruthlessly
smart and articulate and capable of
shutting down these stammering liberals
that day or go and question her,
her narrative.
Then all of a sudden she's on NBC like
you can't do that.
That's a terrible move.
Like they're not going to accept you.
This is not going to work in the ratings
have been horrendous and now she's free
and now they pulled the show.
It pulled the show early,
but it just goes to show like,
you know,
we rightly attack people like Info laws
for spreading,
you know,
outright lies.
Yes.
But we on the left like Megan Kelly
editing that segment to make it look
like she was poised and perfect at all.
Alex does this dominant sweat.
What's very hard,
very hard sell.
Saying that Megan Kelly is on the left,
which is on the left.
Now what I mean like the mainstream,
the main that NBC.
So the mainstream has its own tricks.
It's like,
it's not an outright lie like Alex would
do,
but that,
you know,
pataky,
selective editing,
it's its own.
I would,
I would have imagined that that Julian,
the interview between Alex and Megan
Kelly,
Alex would have said some things that
would,
you know,
eloquent or,
or,
or sentence without a sweat.
I'm sure its own.
Well here's also the problem and having
any sort of a conversation about any
sort of difficult subject and stuffing
it into seven minutes or whatever it is.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's an ancient way of communicating and
now that we have the Internet and Alex
is shown with his own show,
you know,
that he can go and rant about something
and you know,
for 15 minutes,
whatever it is,
like an with no limitations or
restrictions like that.
It's,
it's a better way to communicate.
And one of the things that I wanted to
do when I had alex on the podcast is I
wanted people to see the Alex that I
know because there's no other way to see
him like that.
I wanted to get him drunk.
I wanted to get them high and I wanted
to have him talk.
And my friend Eddie,
who's so in a conspiracy,
he kind of fucked some of it because
he's just so into chem trails and
proving the chem trails are real.
But it was good overall because it's
like he was.
Alex is so crazy that even eddie was
like,
what does a couple of moments where
Eddie turned to look at Alex?
He goes,
what the fuck?
Like what he's talking about
interdimensional child molesters.
And it's.
I wanted people to see him the way I see
it.
He's a fun guy that I like hanging out
with.
Do I think that he has a lot of
influence?
Yeah.
Do I think he says things that he
definitely shouldn't say?
Of course.
Especially the sandy hook stuff.
I mean,
I think this inclination to always look
towards conspiracy is dangerous.
It's harmful.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's dangerous in that people are easily
led.
And if you get people thinking that
everything's a conspiracy,
the real problem is they don't know what
the fuck a conspiracy actually is when
it's in front of them and it's real and
there's a ton of them that are real.
So when you call,
you're crying wolf around every corner
and then all of a sudden you turn a
corner like,
Holy Shit,
that's a real wolf.
No one is listening.
So I agree that that's my frustration
with Alex too,
is that he has a conspiracy template on
what?
For real world event happens.
He had shoe horns into this kind of
simplistic template.
Yeah,
he's got some crazy ideas about Mars.
There's bay or no,
was it the moon?
There's bases on the moon that they're
going to all the time.
Is that what he's saying?
He's got some crazy moon thing.
Like he thinks that they.
Well they went on the moon.
The problem is what they found up there,
like he's got the goat spied to hybrid
that he talks about is true though he
doesn't express it very well,
but I learnt in this measurement and
Monistat soda those years ago that they
really would like,
um,
they really were a mixing up spy to silk
with goat milk.
Here we go.
Some kind of Alex Jones reveals the
truth about animal human hybrids and the
moon landing.
The real problem.
Give us some.
Give us some volume here because Alex,
uh,
bleeding from your face left.
Yes.
Oh,
we're scared.
You're so mean.
It's like Kathy Griffin simulating
murdering trump when trump says,
you ought to be ashamed of yourself.
She was like,
how dare you,
you broke me.
You talked me.
I'm a victim of pause right then the
run.
I agree with him 100 percent on that.
I felt like that was so preposterous and
I like Kathy as a person.
I've met her a 100 times.
Kathy Griffin,
she's always sweet,
but when she was saying that he's a
bully and he broke me and I was like,
oh my God,
you.
She held up a photo of his headless body
that his children could have seen or it
is not as headless body.
His head separated from his body that
his children could have seen.
Like,
is that like,
what is that like,
that's,
that's it's so effective.
It didn't.
And then for her to say that he broke
her,
he's a bully.
Like all he did was say it was horrible.
Yeah.
Like that he's targeting her.
It's like this whole,
like professional victim thing that
people enjoy,
they enjoy,
like taking on the role with such.
They have such energy.
They put two being the victim.
It's just God,
you shouldn't hold up pictures of
people's heads.
Okay.
If you don't like them.
I mean,
especially like in this day and age when
there's people that actually cut
people's heads off and been show them on
camera and me,
this is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
You know,
by the way,
speaking of cutting people's heads off
and show them on camera,
uh,
around the time that I was hanging out
with Alex at payment grove,
I was hanging out documenting this
Islamic militant Chordoma Mohammed who
was the head of this group in Britain.
Go download hydroone and a bunch of his
people are the ones who like now drive
fans into pedestrians.
I'd a mixed all of the people with the
craziest and most pernicious idea is
that I hung out with in the days rose to
the top and I'm influenced their worlds.
So including.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
Alex,
I don't think Alex just have political
sway.
Well,
maybe he's right about these animal
human hybrid.
It's go back to that place.
We need to find out what's happening on
the moon.
Did you turn off of it?
Go back to it.
What'd you do?
I think around violence done so many
death reporters.
She broke me.
Looks like the day of the dead on CNN,
just like Kathy Griffin.
I guess that's the look that sucker's
looking for and then they freak out and
go.
You called me irresponsible.
You said that I was a bad person.
I've been crushed by you.
You're a bully.
It's a bunch of corporate special
interests that had their foot or their
knee on our neck and now they don't.
One hundred percent got us on the ground
and they're just flipping out a bunch of
us.
How the fuck fuck
did he go from Kathy Griffin,
who's a comedian who did a gag that she
taught was going to get her attention to
backfire too.
There are a bunch of corporate special
interests who've had their knee on our
neck.
Like what?
So how the fuck is Kathy Griffin and got
her knee and anybody's neck like she's
not a corporation.
She's not special interest.
She's a fucking comic.
I know her.
You can that conspiracy instantaneously.
You looking for the part where it talks
about the moon.
Look ahead and see what this human
animal hybrid thing.
I agree with you that he has too much
influence over some people.
But I disagree in that.
I don't think.
I don't think any of that should be
taken seriously.
Like what,
what he just said should not be taken
seriously.
I mean,
none of this would matter if there
wasn't just the possibility that trump
believes this stuff.
Although I'll tell you what I would say
last summer I was,
when I was,
I've got this book,
the elephant in the room,
try to trace that,
just how it works.
Alex,
buyer,
Roger Stone,
meeting trump and,
and so on.
I discovered one really interesting
thing which is this is something that
Alex didn't like.
Alex did say to me when I was writing
this book,
you could write whatever you want.
I don't care.
Um,
but that turned out to not be entirely
true.
There were things that you did care
about that I wrote.
I'm,
one of them was a talked to Glenn Beck
and he told me to start this before
trump was elected.
He told me this story about how trump
invited him to Mara Largo around the
time that trump was deciding to stand.
And he phoned Glenn Beck even though
they were both at Mara Lago.
Um,
trump was in run one room and Glenn Beck
was in the other hand,
trump found Glenn Beck and said,
I think you have like,
you know,
you're so influential.
You are so great.
You know,
you're great.
You've got such influential can you can
unite the tea party.
And the mainstream Republicans in Glenn
Beck thought,
you know,
fuck you,
I know what you're doing here.
You know,
you're,
you're playing me.
I've been down this road a million
times.
And then trump did the same thing to
Alex.
he phoned Alex and said,
you know,
you have so much influence.
Uh,
you're so amazing.
And Alex bought it because according to
Glenn Beck,
no,
no.
I spoke to both of them.
I mean,
you didn't speak to trump.
I didn't speak to trump,
both Glenn Beck and Alex and I don't
know that Glen Book really did get the
phone call from trump,
right?
Well it was Glenn Beck told me that
either
Glenn Beck has said some pretty
ridiculous shit himself.
It's true.
I only became a mormon at the age of 51.
I only say I only ever read the book so,
um,
but I do think that's convenient.
Like if it's right is convenient.
It makes,
it makes it look interesting.
Although,
well,
I mean that's what Glen Beck told me.
I need a word for that store.
I mean,
you don't really know what I mean.
I come back to me that I believe that if
Donald trump called up Alex and said you
were so influential and you're amazing
and Alice will thank you,
Mr.
President,
we're gonna do our best to keep you in
office.
Fight against the tyranny and all these
fucking people out there that think
they're going to stop.
He's,
he's,
I mean,
that's who he is.
You know,
you can get them riled up.
That's who he is.
But I do.
I do think that Alex has a kind of bit
of a neophyte in,
in all of this because nobody had taken
him that seriously before that nobody in
positions of power are taking them that
seriously.
But here's the deal.
I think trump played alex and Alex was
played.
You might be right,
but if,
if trump turned on Alex and said,
uh,
you know,
in,
for awards is a bunch of losers,
much of this.
Now Alex would,
he would turn it around again and he
would go after trump.
Like he,
he would.
Oh,
Alex is really smart.
Like Alex from the beginning set like
it.
I'm with trump until trump says
something,
you know,
that I don't like it,
then I'll drop them like a hot potato.
So Alex was very smart,
like Alex always gave him.
He gave himself a sort of parachute and
this relationship.
So.
So I think trump played alex and Alex
was a bit too gullible and believed
trump's slick talk.
No,
but Alex was also smart and gave himself
and out whenever he wanted.
The out Alex's goddamned entertaining,
like that alone is fucking entertaining,
especially for me a person.
I'm not going to be influenced by these
things that he says,
but one thing that I have been
influenced his bite him uncovering some
things that are real conspiracies,
one of them being agent provocateurs and
they use to disrupt peaceful protests.
Uh,
this was something that I didn't know
was a,
was a standard tactic by the military
and by certain politicians.
And what they do is they will hire these
people.
I don't know what branch of the
military,
what they do,
but they will hire these people and it's
been confirmed by people that I know
that are like special operators.
They take these masked guys and say if
they have some peaceful protest,
the big one was the World Trade
Organization.
You remember that protest and these guys
with masks and government issued boots
came in,
started smashing windows,
lighting things on fire and that gave
them an excuse to come in and break up
this riot where it had been a peaceful
protest where they couldn't stop the
peaceful protest.
So now they break up these riots that
they've created themselves,
start arresting people left and right.
Then they put up a no protest zone.
This is all documented.
Did you just do some dance music music
on and apparently.
But see this is.
I mean he documented a.
He documented this and has been
documented by many people since then and
and even in legitimate circles like a.
It was a big factor in the occupy Wall
Street movement.
The occupy Wall Street movement was
infiltrated Ad Nauseum by people from
whatever branch of government,
whoever the fuck they were.
But yeah,
what they did was they,
they cause chaos and then it gives me an
excuse to arrest them.
And then in the World Trade Organization
thing,
Alex detailed like with news reports,
independent news reports,
how those people were not arrested and
they were all negotiated,
negotiated their freedom.
They all held up in a house somewhere
and then they got them out of there as
soon as everybody kind of forgot about
it all,
and then they set up a no protest zone
and the no protests.
Owen was fascinating because there's a
lot of people that disagreed with the
policies of the World Trade Organization
and these people were going to work with
a pin on a backpack or a jacket that
said dubby too,
and had a line through it.
The police told them they could not go
through with the pin on.
They could not go to work with a pin on
that had a line through the word WTO,
like they opposed the WTO.
This is a no protest zone.
Wow.
That's Alex Jones showed that.
So as Wacky as he might be about alien
babies are coming from another dimension
that here to steal your soul and make
you vote.
Libertarian like he,
he,
he might be wrong about a lot of shit,
but he also,
he's got the balls to expose a lot of
crazy shit that people didn't talk
about.
Yeah.
It reminds me of the time I went to
Arian nations just before it closed
down.
Remember Eddie nations?
What is it?
Idaho.
Oh,
they had that.
There was like near Boise or right?
Yeah,
a camp.
Oh,
quarter lane.
That's what your leg.
Which is gorgeous.
As crazy as that crazy lake up there.
They have.
Yes.
Beautiful.
So I was making a documentary about
Randy Weaver about ruby rich spending
lots of time with Randy's daughter
Rachel,
who I liked a lot.
Anyway,
part of the reason why the whole ruby
rich escalation happened was because
randy wavered come to people.
A lot of people don't know that story,
but I tell the story.
Yeah,
okay.
So it was a family of white separatists,
a rotten day,
and becky and their children,
Sarah and Rachel and a boy whose name
I've forgotten people will be.
It'll come to me anyway.
So they moved to Idaho early,
you know,
early conspiracy theorists.
They moved to Idaho,
to a,
to a cabin on top of a hill,
a place called Ruby Creek.
Anyway,
Randy and Vicky used to go to area
nations for like their picnics and
barbecues,
but they weren't.
And this is a kind of pivotal points.
They weren't as crazy as the people that
are heavy,
heavier nations.
They weren't white supremacists,
but they were sort of fellow travelers
but not quite as crazy.
So any nations was infiltrated,
lack of white supremacist groups by lots
of federal agents and they saw randy and
thought they could work with them.
So they said to around a,
you know,
will it be an informant for us?
And Randy said,
no.
So then they sent in this guy and asked
randy to soar off a shotgun,
a quarter of an inch below the legal
limit.
Uh,
so randy sort of the shotgun for this
guy.
And then they said,
we're federal agents.
You just committed a,
you're going to go to prison in less
shoe,
become an informant for us against area
nations.
And Randy being a kind of hot headed
idiot,
said,
no,
fuck off.
I made a big show of saying no,
So they went back to their cabins.
They went back to the cabin and a
warrant was issued for Randy's arrest
and rented and turn up to court.
So now the US marshals are like hiding
in the bushes,
looking at randy's cabin,
randy arms,
his kids in his tiny little kids,
you know.
So they're patrolling up and down
outside the cabin with these guns.
They were becoming increasingly paranoid
thinking they were being watched from
the bushes and they were being watched
from the bushes,
CCTV cameras in us marshals.
Anyway,
one day the US marshals got too close to
the cabin and one of Randy's dogs
started barking.
And the kid,
Randy's son came out.
Twelve year old kid.
I'm look much younger.
Look like eight years old came out with
a gun and I'm gunfire happens that the
US marshals shopped the little boy,
nearly shot his arm off and he,
he turned around and tried to run back
to the cabin.
I'm shouting dad and the US Marshall's,
um,
shot him in the back and killed him and
they killed the dog and one US Marshall
was killed.
And there's debate as to whether it was
either the randy son or family friend or
whether it was friendly fire or not.
Uh,
so they got the son's body and put them
in the,
in the cabin.
And the next day this FBI sharp shooter
called alone Horror Yuchi turned up.
So the FBI surrounded the cabin.
US Marshal had been killed.
Um,
there were tanks,
there were hundreds of troops,
this was like in the Clinton nineties
when the Cold War was kind of dying and
they needed a new enemy.
And so the new enemy that week was Randy
Weaver and his family.
So Vicky Weaver with holding their baby
Alicia,
but in the doorway of the cabin,
um,
and the sharp shooter shot Vicky to the
face and then they,
they pulled Vicky's body into the cabin
and a,
on a,
um,
randy was shot as well but survived
under siege and she would have lasted
about two weeks of the kids inside the
cabin and the FBI outside of the cabin,
it ended up ending peacefully.
Boger rights.
There was a bit kind of militia hero to
end up in,
sort of helped to stop it from
happening,
uh,
to,
you know,
helped get randy out of the cabin.
Um,
and in the end,
the daughters each got a million dollars
each compensation and um,
and it all kind of faded away.
So I was making a documentary about all
of this,
uh,
and I went to area nations because I
thought I can just turn up and say I'm
friends with Andy Weaver and they'd let
me in.
So I turned up and immediately ordered
these skinheads surrounded me and
started asking me what my genealogy was
because they thought correctly the Euro
Ju Ju.
So I set a,
what's my genealogy?
This,
that was the word they use.
What's your genealogy?
So I said,
uh,
I said,
I'm Church of England.
Uh,
I'm one of the Nazis.
The area nations made a joke and said
something like,
Oh,
Church of England,
you're the guys who blog our beds.
Some kind of joke and the skinheads sort
of drifted away from me and I'm,
I,
I've always thought that the guy who
alleviated the situation was maybe an
undercover agent who was like calming
things down.
And so protecting me.
So it's crossed my knowing how
infiltrated those groups always are.
Just like the video that you said,
knowing how infiltrated these groups
are,
do they know how infiltrated their,
they must do?
Right.
That's got to be so weird.
I know,
I know they must do a because they were
like,
infiltrate it to fuck.
I mean all of them were.
Well the.
That's one thing the federal government
does good to infiltrate the mob with was
getting people to wear wires.
The good Adat yeah,
January in a wire or I forget where live
there.
So I think,
I think they protected me in that moment
when I could have had the shit kicked
out of me.
You think so?
Yeah.
I found out you were Jewish.
Well,
because I am and I'm obviously fucking
Jewish.
No,
not necessarily.
Do you think people don't know anything
and they think all English people of
color.
It was my own stupid fault.
I drove up the drive past all the signs
that said no Jews,
Jews turn back now as,
as they surrounded me,
I did think to myself like if I get the
APP now,
it's my own stupid fault.
So weird because it's a race and it's
also religion.
It's a weird one.
Yeah.
No,
that's weird,
right?
Yeah,
because you're European,
but you're also Jewish,
which is a religion.
So if you're a European atheist,
are you still a Jew?
Yeah,
well,
I mean I am basically,
I remember when I was to us with Elma
bakary the,
uh,
Islamic fundamentalist and he,
he outed me as a Jew.
It is jihad training camp.
Yes.
Bitch.
A place called Crawley,
which is near Gatwick airport.
How rude.
He said to me,
look at me with the infidel,
John who is a Jew and it all went and I
said,
um,
I said,
surely it's better to be a Jew than an
atheist.
And I heard someone in the crowd go,
no,
it isn't.
The thing that really surprises me about
that exchange is that I am an atheist.
So of all the places where I would
choose for the first time in my life to
cut,
to exert my Jewishness,
I could chose a fucking g had training
camp like wha what?
Self-Defeat you have second thoughts
about that one?
Were you in the midst of those people
going,
what the fuck am I playing with here?
Yes.
Although quite quickly this,
the tension dissipated and I remember
like a bunch of these young radical
Islamists all started asking me like
what it was like to be a Jew.
They will like treating me like a kind
of tropical fish.
You would have babies to slug and I
remember leaving that Jihad training
camp that day thinking I'd done some
sterling work in bringing together
communities and you really believe that
what I thought I believed it till like
nine slash 11,
don't believe it anymore.
I know most people were like,
people in that room at that scout hurt
went on to become suicide bombers and to
kill people and to drive fans into
people.
It was a different world before nine
slash 11 though.
The fear of jihadis was much,
much,
much less prevalent.
Yeah.
I made this funny.
I made this film called talk to
Martello.
I spent a year with Omar Bakri and it
was a kind of comic film about his
attempts to like,
you know,
he said he wouldn't rest until we saw
the flag of Islam flying over Downing
Street.
So we made this sort of almost comic
film about his sort of blundering
attempts to create like Sharia law in
Britain and the joke of the film is at
ice is never gonna work and it was kind
of,
you know,
some of his ideas were ridiculous.
Like at one point he had these 5,000
black balloons carrying the call to war
and these little,
like little leaflets like attached to
these balloons,
uh,
we'd like to slogans like Islam is the
future of Britain and they were going to
like fly over London and La land
wherever,
but they hadn't properly calculated like
the,
the weight ratio,
these fucking balloon let them off.
They go,
just like stayed on the floor.
So all year they will like failing at
doing everything.
Uh,
but yeah,
but len lye,
this is like 96 and then five years
later,
nine slash 11 happened.
And now Omar's in prison in Beirut for
inciting terrorism.
And a lot of Omar's people became
terrorists.
True.
Jon Ronson,
you'd been around.
I've been around the block.
I've seen some shift.
So when was the last time you were in
Alex's presence?
Uh,
does texting count?
No.
Have you been around him?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I was,
I went to visit her info wars last
summer.
Last August.
And what did you think of him?
Like knowing him in the late nineties
when you guys wanted to Bohemian Grove
together and knowing him now?
Well,
I mean it's operation has expanded
massively.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
When I knew Alex in the nineties,
Info wars was a spare bedroom
in his house with Choo Choo train
wallpaper,
trains at an empire strikes back poster.
It was Alex,
Mike Hanson,
Alex's girlfriend.
They always called a violet that have
real name Kelly.
Um,
I said to her because I went to the
custody hearing for a couple of days.
Oh.
So I saw them.
Then I went to the custody hearing
because I was just curious and I said to
a lot the last time I saw the two of
you,
you were like kissing and telling each
other how much he loved each other.
And then like 16 years passes and it's
the worst.
Like divorce at Texas has ever known.
That's what divorce lawyers were saying,
like in the worst.
Oh,
they just because we went national and
they just hated each other.
So much hate each other.
So I say like,
yeah,
I'm a.
Now Alex has got a staff of like 75
people,
uh,
you know,
with like these giant Tiger's for his
supplement is male vitality supplements.
Have you ever seen the video of when
Joey Diaz and me are in our studio and
Joey realizes that it's on the intranet,
so because it's on the Internet and he
could say whatever he wants.
So we go,
we go live in our schools.
Uh,
well actually from here on out,
we're on the Internet so you can kind of
say whatever you want,
but try to keep it clean.
And the look of it for Joey Diaz,
it was like the cat who saw the canary
and realize that the cage was open and
he was.
So he's telling some story about
smuggling weed through the airport.
Listen to this,
listen to your bullshit congressmen or
your bullshit governor or even a
bullshit presence as a political
resonance.
Same Shit because they give you every
four fucking years
still vote for the fucking Momo.
And then you get mad about me saying the
word fuck with that.
Amadea was considered very solid points.
Don't do.
I don't know.
I know Joe,
you get it.
But then just to let the American public
know that every four years they buy the
same shit they been buying for years at
the same people with the articulation
and the holiday don't curse.
And they are Christians and they had a
family and these are the same people
that shove it up your fucking ass every
year.
The one thing that you'll get,
I'll say fuck,
but I will not fuck around you.
If I need something,
I'll ask you like a man.
You're going to go fuck yourself.
You've cut.
Hold on.
Hold on one second.
Hey,
good job.
Take a shuttle.
Joey Diaz.
Facebook.
Check yourself before you wreck
yourself.
Big Dixon.
Yes.
Get out of here.
You're in trouble.
I'm powered fire.
This is the.
I'm drawing a blank because that's the
most important.
Oh,
okay.
Hey,
he made a speech.
He's a funny.
It's military lived.
Do you think Alex had all solar?
This is great.
I have a good time without telling,
you know,
when I say all of this,
I mean,
do you think Alex,
the fact that the know that the
spotlight is on them in a kind of
unprecedented,
famous like stressed out?
Honestly,
I don't think he,
I've never met a guy in my life that has
more teflon when it comes to stress.
Like I'm stressed out lately,
but I go to the gym and feel fine,
had a cheeseburger,
probably shouldn't have that shit.
Try to stick to my diet.
But it's hard when he's.
He doesn't give a fuck man.
Like he's a weird guy.
Like he's got a very unusual
constitution.
You know what I bet did stress them out
though.
Uh,
there was a couple of pending lawsuits
like Chobani and Barney wasn't mean to
body through yoga.
People Buy Yogurt.
Yeah.
He got into trouble with Chobani because
he said they will like importing
rapists.
Um,
and of course he got into trouble with
the pizza restaurant and I would bet me
pizza gate,
that Shit your info wars.
Alex Jones apologized for saying Shabani
supports migrant rapists.
He didn't really say,
Oh,
Jesus Christ,
he said me so fucking I would go into
you that I would guarantee you that and
the pizza gate stuff properly stressed
about because I think both of those were
risking his entire operation.
Okay.
Let me tell you something.
It might stress you out,
like if it was you and you were being
sued by Shabani,
you'd probably freaking out and be like,
alright,
I've clearly made it horrible mistake.
I need to come clean and I need to
apologize.
I'm so paranoid that I freak out if I
eat a Chibani guava and think I'm like,
fuck,
this is the most disgusting thing I've
ever.
And I,
I my,
my,
my threshold for getting like,
panicky and stressed out is very low.
That's incredible considering you are in
a jihadi camp.
Yeah,
I know.
I,
I often wonder why I put myself.
Maybe that's why it's so compelling when
you do.
Yeah.
But Alex doesn't new,
right?
No,
I know him,
man.
He's,
he's a different dude.
You know,
like he's got like,
there's,
I don't agree with a lot of the stuff he
says,
just like I don't agree with a lot of
stuff my friend Eddie says,
but I love the both of them.
It's,
it's weird man.
And I get it.
I get people saying that he's got too
much influence and he does know my take
is like if you really think there's
fucking alien bases on the moon and that
there's child slaves on Mars,
fucking shame on you.
Shame on you.
You know,
I think the deeper and the more crazy he
goes,
the better his show is more.
I mean,
I'm a bad person for that.
I don't think I am though.
You come in wondering why I put myself
in dangerous situations that would
really thinking about it a little bit.
Maybe.
Maybe it's because people who have
anxiety disorders,
uh,
quite good when it comes to actual
difficult situations because we've
rehearsed it so many times.
Like we panic unnecessarily so often the
when something really worth panicking
comes along.
We actually handled it really well.
Well,
let me ask you,
has there ever been a situation where
you were confronted with an idea and
you're like,
you know what,
that one is too dangerous.
I'm not doing that.
Yeah.
When I was writing the manifesto goats,
uh,
the metastatic goats was about this kind
of secret unit in the eighties of like
soldiers who were trying to like walk
through walls and visible and kills that
remote viewing as well.
Remote viewing was that,
there was a,
they were,
they were different,
but there was an overlap.
I met a bunch of those guys,
right.
I was doing that so far show right now
Joel mcmonagle and that day to remember
their names.
I met with him talking to me about how
they found,
you know,
various bad people using this weird
stuff.
And I was like,
MMM,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
no,
I.
So I met all of those people to remote
viewing sounds like really exciting,
but you know,
psychic spies in the military.
But it turns out that actually their
labs were quite shit because basically
there's the fucking room or they try to
like psychically sketch like 20th and
every one of them told me that,
um,
because they were black up because they
didn't officially exist,
you have no coffee machine had to like
bring them coffee into work every day
because they couldn't justify having
also the,
the,
the room that they have been was really
bad because they couldn't get it
repaired because they didn't exist.
Yeah.
Um,
so their lives are quite shit.
So I tell her how I,
how I came to this story.
So that was out.
This guy called Jim Schnabel had written
this book called remote viewers,
which kind of,
you know,
uncovered all of that stuff.
And there was this magician called ray
hyman who was like a skeptic.
I think he's dead now.
The CIA brought him in to assess the
remote viewing program to see whether
they should keep it going or close it
down.
Um,
and ray hyman said it was kind of
nonsense.
And so that helped them.
The CIA close down the unit.
So I met Ray hyman and I just happened
to say to him,
it's like one of those questions that
kind of changes your life.
I said to him like,
so when you were like in the military,
like sniffing around with the remote
view is,
did you happen to notice anything else
going on anywhere you went?
Yeah.
He said there was this general called
stubble bine who thought he could like
burst clouds with his mind and there's
this kernel called Channon who thought
that he could lie,
you know,
train soldiers to like fast for a month.
And so I had these two names,
stubble bone and Shannon and the whole
metastatic goat stuff,
which,
which wasn't out in the open all came
out.
It was amazing that they were trying to
kill goats just by staring at them
[inaudible].
So yeah.
So they had,
like,
I've,
I met this guy who was that part of the
goat staying program and they had like,
this is all at Fort Bragg.
Um,
I had a trip around Fort Bragg one time
and I to them like,
so where's Gottlieb?
Otherwise,
you're not supposed to know about clap
lap.
Yeah.
Um,
so they had like a one point,
they had like 30 goats in a room and
they were all staring at to 16.
They were like numbers on their backs
and go number 17 fell over,
which I suppose there's collateral
damage.
Uh,
I mean I would,
I would argue that if he stared at it
long enough it's going to fall over.
I mean,
everything's going to fall over
eventually.
Sorry.
I was drinking water when I was
laughing.
Okay.
Sorry.
God really did fall over and die.
Well No.
Oh well guys,
severely.
So we tracked down the Goat Stereo.
This is two.
He now runs a dance studio in Ohio,
the severely dance and martial arts
studios.
So we tracked him down.
I said,
I said to him on the phone,
so do you still ever kill goats?
Just by staring at them and he went
with,
with a matter of fact.
Just last week I,
I killed my hamster just by staring at
him,
be like three days old.
He said,
he said,
he said he caught it on video and I
said,
well,
can we come and watch the video?
So we weren't said,
okay.
So we flew to Ohio to meet guys
severely.
Uh,
the whole time his son was filming me
like the whole time I was there he was
filming me.
So eventually he admitted like why they
were filming me and it was that he was
worried that I might be al-Qaida let
China learn how to stare at people and
kill them.
Yes.
So he was like filming me,
just inserting really believed it.
Totally.
So will this video,
did it show him staring in Hampshire and
I saw the video of the hamster staring.
I should tell you about the way that
the,
the moment when I think I've pinpointed
the moment when they worked out that I
wasn't Al-qaida and it was because it
turns out that guy severely,
his daughter is in the movie Chicago,
like is one of the dances.
And so I Kinda,
I kinda shrieked Oh I,
oh I love Catherine Zeta Jones.
And I think they all kind of like a kind
of deep cover.
Al Qaeda operative wouldn't think to go
that feminists.
Uh,
so,
uh,
yeah.
So then they showed me the hubs to
video.
It's a hamster.
I'm sure this is on youtube by the way.
I'm,
I'm sure you can find this.
It's if you typed in,
I don't know,
Jon Ronson,
hamster,
crazy roads of the World Guy Savannah
was so like,
he's like,
so perhaps just like running around in
its wheel and that guy's off camera,
like staring at the hamster.
And then finally the Hampton gets off
the whale and it's like all the sawdust
and then the hamster light drops,
light stops moving,
drops down and stops moving amid the
sawdust.
So I'm like,
whoa.
And then the hamster gets up again and
the video ends.
So I was like,
that's not that guy said he flew all the
way to Ohio.
I see a video of a hamster guy said,
yeah,
yeah.
My wife,
my wife told me like,
not to.
My wife said,
don't show them the part with a hamster
dies.
What?
Yeah,
in case I was like a bleeding heart
liberal and his wife told him to not
show you the video that you flew all the
way to fuck to Ohio to see what.
I think it's possible that that just
doesn't die.
I'm no way,
Bro,
but it's true.
The guy showed me like a whole full
screen.
Please.
You need to put it goes belly up,
man.
Hey,
what happens when you've got a guest
who's on for three hours and they want
to use the birth?
Just go into a bathroom.
Good.
Can you cover for.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll turn the volume here.
Okay.
Oh,
he's doing some fake martial arts too.
you don't understand.
This is my favorite stuff.
Jon Ronson.
Look at this.
This is my favorite stuff.
It's all like pokes triangle.
Oh,
it's called the triangle of death.
I'll go back to that.
I will need you to watch that again.
This just hilarious.
The arteries,
the sophos airway.
Yeah.
Helping a person.
You're hurting a person.
They need a clear airway.
They need to be able to breathe and they
need to have circulation of blood.
So their body pause every second.
What's one thing about bullshit artists
use these real technical terms,
like especially in martial arts,
bullshit artists,
they always talk about like,
uh,
like medical terms that they're
destructing the nerve,
the vegas nerve that goes to the brain
and the,
this is your c,
six c,
seven cervical disc and I'm going to
tack the cervical disc through the
carotid artery.
They're all like,
is almost like they learn all these
technical terms to sorta make their
horseshit look more palatable
in order to live in the poison,
the poison hands showing you how to
strike,
to penetrate the skin,
of which we have a way to do that.
Please don't show anything
buddy,
sir,
with your flabby grandma arms.
He's going to watch.
He's going to show you.
Oh boy.
The alive.
It's just the end part is my favorite.
Where he does like the fucking karate
stands behind them.
The guys back.
Sit Your Little Lulu.
Pan To the back.
Uh,
guys.
Wonderful.
I don't know why man.
I don't know why,
but it still gives me so much pleasure.
I enjoy fake martial arts videos more
than almost anything more,
almost as much as hold this beer,
that twitter account that I fucking
every two days after retweet one because
I find a good new one.
I don't know why he's got new stuff.
Oh,
what's he going to do?
Mine Development.
Oh,
mind developed.
Let me see this.
Let me see.
This guy's Culligan close.
He's touching him.
He's about to touch him.
What the fuck was that?
You guys have had to touch him.
Means that you can do whatever has to be
done to protect.
Not hurt.
These kids here,
this development of the so you know you
have to ship the me,
right?
This isn't.
This is your bread and butter.
This is well content.
This is something I've been doing more
than ever doing anything in my whole
life.
This is the first real exercise towards
that goal.
You,
Kevin.
It's so fucking stupid.
He's the goat stuff and the going to
punch a watermelon,
right?
Oh,
you're crazy,
bro.
Watermelon Salad.
Oh,
no way.
That's impenetrable.
It's basically a brick wall.
Fingers.
I'm just gonna.
Use his fingers.
One,
two.
Oh,
I broke his hand,
son,
you broke your hand,
kid.
He's the first guy to tell me about the
dim mak.
The debt touch.
He went right through that watermelon,
bro.
I would let that guy do that to me.
I'd be like,
okay,
fuck the watermelon dude.
Let me tighten up my stomach.
Oh yeah,
I've seen.
I've seen this stuff.
This is this guy doing military stuff,
right?
This is.
This is deep.
This is really military,
but he's wearing a military out.
Hey,
I do know that guy went to Fort Bragg
and depakote stuff like he showed me
documentation,
but see this right here.
Listen man.
I used to do this.
Look stupid.
He picked his leg up when he's doing it.
Oh,
this is hilarious.
Kids can do at his fingertips.
Hi My right.
Well,
here's the thing.
When I was a kid,
like real young,
we used to do these demonstrations when
I was like 15,
right?
When we would open up a new school,
would you do these demonstrations?
And it was the only time we ever broke
boards.
We fucking never presents really easy to
do.
Looks hard to the desert,
but working on hot coals right?
It's way easier than walking on hot
coals because those things,
first of all,
the way they're cut is with the car.
Like the grain is a.
it's going in a matter of how.
What's the way we describe it.
So they give you.
You're holding something up.
The is actually going in the way that
you want it to break.
So you're breaking it with the grain you
literally can do with your fingers like
I could.
You could take.
Those are thin pieces of wood to you can
take this piece of if this would,
if this pad was a would you would just
go like this with two fingers,
just go snap and would break bricks like
nothing.
I was 15 and when we do this,
karate kicks and punches and stuff,
they always broke,
always broke.
So what are so easy to break?
So here's the question now,
what does it say about like special
forces at Fort Brag that they would
bring a guy in today?
They brought that guy in.
Well,
I mean it wasn't like.
I don't,
I don't believe it was like an sanction
from the very top,
but he certainly went to Fort Bragg and
stared at goats.
He stared at goats at Fort Bragg.
Well,
they're probably just grabbed whatever
dummies they could find like it gets.
Some dudes want to stare at a goat.
Like there's a lot of people though.
Here's one thing that is a fact.
There's a lot of people,
particularly in the eighties and the
nineties before the ultimate fighting
championship came around.
There was a lot of fake martial arts out
there.
A lot.
I know people that were teaching fake
martial arts that got into the military
that got into the police.
I knew the guy who was deep in the
police force and he had fake martial
arts,
like his martial arts.
We're fucking completely useless and it
tallies with the US military Crete
olive,
like thinking out the box,
like if we don't try this stuff,
nobody else will try.
This is going on here.
They're blurring easy.
It is to break that.
This special forces,
special special ops.
Okay.
So yeah,
there you go.
I never killing goats con.
Wow.
I've never even heard of that one thing,
but then stepper,
pride,
general stuff about who I'm sure would
have been a fan of this show because he
was,
he was a big fan of Alex's and so on.
So he was head of army intelligence.
He had 16,000
soldiers under his command and he
totally believed in all of this stuff.
He believed in that stuff.
But that guy was doing general stubble.
Stubborn would when he was head of army
intelligence in Arlington would try and
walk through his walled,
uh,
because he told me one time,
he said like,
he said,
what is the atom mostly made up of
space?
What is the wall mostly made up of
atoms.
I mean,
to me the key word this is most mostly a
big part of that.
He would like stand up from behind his
desk.
I'm like,
you know,
basically run into,
you should have asked him,
what's an atom bomb made up?
You fucking idiot.
He said,
let me show you a video.
He that he would like,
bruises knows.
He said fortunately he was going through
a messy divorce at the time.
So like,
like other people in his office just
assumed it was like,
you know,
his wife beater market,
but in fact he was trying to get away
from this wall walk and an asshole.
He was trying to merge the spaces
between that and just kept pumping his
nose.
Yeah.
This is,
this is,
yeah.
This was fun.
This,
my couple of years and when I did the a
Scifi show,
we did a whole segment on remote viewing
and we actually had a guy who claimed to
be a successful remote viewer and we,
we set up this location and asked him,
me and Dj growthy Oh yeah,
yeah.
Who's a skeptic.
Yeah.
Very nice guy.
And,
and you know,
Dj was just as accurate,
just guessing,
right?
Because this guy was.
Yeah.
I think actually now that I think about,
I think Dj was more accurate,
you know,
the um,
yeah,
the kind of dark secret remote feeling
world.
I'm an account,
you can't sort of totally blame the
remote viewers for this.
But.
So the remote viewing unit for made got
declassified and shut down.
So a lot of these remote viewers then
set up their own training centers,
including the Danes in,
I don't know,
maybe in Vegas,
some or some are not.
So at Dame's had this student
cool
neato says,
Hey,
um,
there was a woman called court May and
then there was this other students have
gotten their names anyway,
but they would then.
So at times taught them remote viewing,
these two people who would then go on
the art bell show and they became light
lie,
you know,
regular guests on the show and they're
the ones.
Then these two have ed dames and
students.
They're the ones who basically announced
on the bell show that the Hale Bopp
comet had a companion object in its
tail.
It remote viewed that help up comment
that was about to pass over the earth,
how to companion object in its tail and
listening to the art bell show was the
heaven's Gate Group.
So they decided that that was the
spaceship they were waiting for.
Yes.
So they all killed themselves to get on
the spaceship.
Prudence,
Kalibrasi and another guy whose name I
forgot.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
So that's the sort of weird butterfly
effect.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
That whole thing was such a,
it's amazing where people want to
believe now this,
when it goes back to conspiracy
theorists or whether it's um,
the remote viewers or even someone who
would watch that guy's karate videos and
think that he's really doing death
touches.
He's talking about it as a method of
going through the skin to attack the
Oregon.
So.
Oh yeah.
He told me all of that said,
oh,
he showed me a photograph of um,
uh,
well actually he accidentally showed me
a photograph of him karate chopping a
goat that you weren't supposed to see
that one.
Yeah,
he did.
He did the death touch on a goat.
A lot of what you could fuck a goat up
if you hit it in the right spot.
Yeah.
A lot of indignities meted out to goats
in the US military.
Got.
You're actually pretty tough though,
now that I think about it.
I bet you probably couldn't kill a goat
with a karate chop.
Right?
I mean,
you have to really
hit it hard in the bright spot in the
neck.
Is it true that in the movie adaptation
of my book,
the metastatic goats,
there's a kind of bit of comedy where
somebody thinks that they fell victim to
the death touch that,
but it happened like years later,
25 years ago,
he was given the death touch and now
he's dying from it.
Twenty five years later was in the
movie.
Yeah.
That was in the movie.
Is it true in like the death touch world
and the world?
Is it true that some people think like
you can touch them now and that's the
moment.
It was great.
Yeah.
Uh,
that's the moment.
So you're saying,
so is it true in the death touch world
that people think you can do the dim
back on someone and they'd die years
later of seemingly natural causes?
I'm sure that someone who believes that
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean if you see that guy that was just
having,
did you see that guy who did all the
crazy stuff and the guy falls down?
You might have missed it.
Yeah,
but that's the movie.
That's the movie based.
Oh,
you mean in the load?
Yeah.
The other guy,
he does all the this using an English
word for you.
He does all these crazy like fake karate
moves up.
Slap,
slap,
slap someone.
Yeah.
There's people that believe all kinds of
crazy stuff.
Well,
you know,
he definitely inspired the characters
into metastatic goats movie.
Have you ever seen what happens when one
of these fake death touch guys fights a
real fighter?
No.
Did I kind of get to shit,
get terrific.
There's a few of them racked and these
guys just don't seem to learn.
One of them that was recently in China
was so,
so poorly received that the guy who was
the MMA fighter had to go into hiding
because he beat the living fuck out of
this guy in like 10 seconds later the
guy came out and did all this crazy
stuff when they go to smashes him in the
face,
mma style and his con food's no good
this day.
Watch this.
So you're the young guy in orange shoes
who's like a legit fighter.
And then the other guy who is this silly
death touch guy dressed up like he's in
a different century and like,
watch how this goes down because it's
horrible because this guy on the left
with the orange sneakers on is a real
train fighter and this other guy has a
real belief in this system that he's
been practicing under and he has no idea
that it's horseshit and the way finds
out that it's horseshit is on youtube.
I mean he literally finds out in this
moment that what he's doing,
he probably believed it.
He brought,
probably believed that what he does is
actually real and effective.
So check this out.
It's horrible.
The good together,
Blah Blah Blah.
They go over what you're supposed to do
or whatever.
And they,
I don't know if they make
them shake hands,
you shake hands and then they go back
and then they get the party started and
it takes 10 seconds.
Here we go,
ready?
Set,
go.
There it goes.
So this guy's like literally doing like
some movie stuff and the boom,
the MMA guy just starts taking off.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
And that's a wrap.
It's horrible.
Oh,
I mean it literally last once he engages
in the last 10 seconds.
But that's because one of them is doing
an actual martial art and the other guys
practicing nonsense and he's probably
practiced that nonsense his whole life.
He thought it was real.
There's another one where there's an old
man and that's even harder to watch
because there's old man gets kicked in
the face and you just go,
oh Jesus Christ,
like save this guy.
This was horrible.
And he looks like legitimately like
let's watch what he does back it up,
up to the beginning.
So he bet $5,000,
check this out,
look what he thinks he can do.
He claimed a 200 and orx.
Look,
he's not even touching these people.
They just go flying.
It's like they're a part of a cult,
you know?
So they move at him and he really firmly
believes that he can do this.
Look,
he's like manipulating them.
Like he's a puppet master.
It's so crazy.
So this guy is so.
He's so like hypnotized by his own
bullshit that he decides,
well he's,
well,
I don't know.
See,
here's the thing,
because he actually makes a real fight
with a real trained martial artist.
So he might,
he may very well have been in on it
himself.
I mean not being what I mean is he
might've been taken by his own bullshit.
He might've actually believed it.
So now he's gonna fly an actual,
a young actual martial artist.
And so he's got this crazy idea that
he's just going to like give that guy
the hex and the guy is going to go
flying through the air like the other
guy was teaching.
But this kid just sort of circles,
um,
for a few seconds.
And then just like that other video
pizza,
holy fuck.
Out of them inside of about 10 seconds,
just zoom off until they engage.
Yeah.
So here it goes.
See?
He's like,
dude,
all this craziness.
And the young martial artists just grabs
him,
punches him,
kick some.
And he's like,
you see,
he like,
he's holding his face is like,
what the fuck?
And the young guys,
really nice look.
He's like,
you,
okay,
you want to keep going?
And he's holding his mouth.
Look,
the young guy like literally says,
look,
does he want to keep going?
Let's stop.
[inaudible] guy's bleeding out of his
nose.
And so he says,
keep going.
He says
I'm fine.
And so he gets his hands up,
but he's now this time it's going to
work.
This time I'm going to hit them with the
full Voodoo and this kid just blam Blam,
blam.
And then this kick boom.
That's where it gets horrific.
And that guy's probably like 60.
It's not,
not a good time to get kicked in the
face,
you know,
in the military.
I'm remembering,
I don't think about the metastatic that
matched it was so long ago,
but now I'm remembering some of the
other,
some of the other stuff that they were
doing.
And there was a lot of weaponry stuff,
you know,
there was the,
um,
there was the prophet,
Hologram,
all of this sort of came from this
central well of like,
you know,
eighties profit,
hologram that,
that they would,
um,
they never liked got it off the ground,
but what they were trying to do with
have a Hologram of Allah that they would
project over an enemy capital.
We're an.
Allah would basically say whatever the u
s military wanted him to say,
Americans aren't that bad.
They are blessed.
President Bush,
they had a race specific stink bomb,
which again,
they never managed to get off the
ground.
What about the gay bomb?
They were,
they had the gay bomb.
That was real.
Yeah.
They literally were engineering some
sort of a chemical warfare device that
would turn men homosexual and lit lit.
And what's less known about it is that
they will also trying to do a halitosis
bomb so that you'd turn the enemy gay.
And then he gave him bad breath.
You haven't gave him bad breath.
And I'd be like so freaked out that the
Americans were.
They'd come in and when they would just
have shame all around.
Yeah,
they,
they had um,
attack attack bees.
Uh,
that would again just attack the enemy.
None of these things got off the ground,
I don't think.
I guess it's sort of like writing
comedy.
You throw a lot of shit against the wall
and like one 10th of it sticks.
Yeah.
And some things did stick right.
I immediately,
the Taser gave me from the military,
but that seems totally reasonable
though.
Everybody knows you can get
electrocuted.
I figured out a way to get a large
charge and a small device.
Yeah.
And there was all this kind of weird,
our old,
our old techniques that they would do it
on to animo in Abu Ghraib or Romania or
oral.
Yeah.
I probably said it wrong.
Where they would like play executive
templates.
Subliminal sounds blast.
They'd blast like Metallica at people,
but laced into metallica would be these
like subliminal sounds that will try to
hypnotize people.
Do you remember when they used to do
that in movie theaters?
Hungry Popcorn?
They live like subliminal images that
will like in between like one fifth of a
second one frame has ever been shown
that that actually worked.
Works.
I'm not sure that I ever worked in the.
I met this guy.
Oh my God.
I just remembered.
So I met this guy called Jamal Harris
who had been released from Guantanamo
and he was telling me about all of this
stuff.
He was in Guantanamo for like two years
and then he got released and he was
telling me about this app.
He said they played him and entire cd
have a fleetwood Mac cuff band,
abnormal in Guantanamo at normal volume.
Those guys are just fucking winging it,
winging it.
What was going on?
I didn't know.
I'm set up with.
They're doing it to be nice and maybe
they thought you want to make it more
pleasant and he said this.
It was good to me.
They weren't trying to be nice.
Anyway,
I saw,
I interviewed Jamal Harris was telling
me about all of this weird shit and few
months ago he goes and fucking joins
isis and blows himself up somewhere.
This guy,
the fleetwood Mac cover band guy.
Wow.
When they arrested him and brought him
to Guantanamo Bay,
was he innocent of those charges?
Well,
he certainly convinced everybody that he
was a.
and uh,
in fact Tony Blair got involved and
helped get him out of one on to be a
jihadi.
What?
I don't know,
but I'd be very curious to find out
which is exactly the question that you
just post.
Like was he always it or did the
experience of being in Guantanamo
somehow years later,
you know,
help to turn him into a god?
I don't know the answer to.
I think if you're an innocent person and
for two years they take away your
freedom and they make you listen to
fleetwood Mac cover band,
you probably feel like I can't get over
that man.
It's stained.
It stained my soul.
I have no idea.
But I met this guy very personable young
man.
I met him at a hotel in Manchester where
I interviewed him for the monster go.
And where do you,
where did he kill himself?
I can't remember.
Can you can look at other people as
well?
I don't know,
Jamal,
I'll also heartbreakingly from around
that time.
Omar Bakri,
who was the guy that she had this,
I made a film about his son.
He had this really sweet little kid,
the son,
Mohammed,
who was really scared that like as far
they might get hurt because he was so
public and open and he would like to
confide in us that,
you know,
he was scared that his father would get
hurt fucking two years ago.
Jordan's son joins Isis,
uh,
tries to leave Isis.
So Isis,
kill him.
I know all these.
All these people I knew 20 years ago,
I tell you all the worse it would go to
Bella killed were to carry out a suicide
curb.
Mean in an army base.
Yeah,
she uses.
I know,
I know.
What does that feel like when you hear
that you lose someone that became a
suicide bomber?
I was,
I was.
Well tomorrow.
I just met that one time.
And still you knew him well,
I met him that one time.
Someone on my podcast.
It turned out to be a suicide bomber
where you did hope.
No,
you give me an f.
no,
I thought you were saying I didn't.
I didn't know.
I thought you were saying that you did.
But he did have a guy on my podcast at
almost beat a woman to
death after he was on and now he's in
jail for life.
Shit.
Yeah.
It was a very public story.
He's a MMA fighter named war machine.
His name's John John Copeland Hammer.
Right.
And uh,
he apparently found this girl he was
dating,
but they broke up.
He found her in bed with another man and
when the beating him and beating her
half to death,
like ruptured her liver broker ribs,
smashed her face,
broker teeth.
Horrific,
horrific.
And she was here with him.
Uh,
what do you think?
Do you think it was steroids to the
goodwill is psychopathy?
Um,
all the above.
I think steroids probably played a
factor.
Traumatic brain injury probably paid a
Um,
I think that's what they say about Chris
Penn Law,
right?
That it was traumatic brain injury.
It's a huge factor because these guys,
they,
they get hit in the head so many times
and no,
no one can tell you when it's going to
go bad.
No one knows.
It's,
it varies.
Like you might be able to take a 100
punches.
For me it might be 30,
you know,
no one knows it doesn't,
it doesn't really make sense.
Yeah.
And you don't know what they're
absorbing and training versus what
happens in actual fights in,
you know,
and what the effect it has on one person
is very differently affected house and
another person also.
Um,
how uh,
how much time is in between these
beatings that they've received?
Are they receiving them on a regular
basis?
It changed them like instantaneously.
I know far too many people that have
experienced a lot of,
a lot of shots to the head where it's
completely changed who they are.
Right,
right.
This guy was troubled to begin with.
I mean he,
he saw his father die beaten up by cops,
wasn't at the store.
I think that was a store something
fucked up experience at a very young
age.
I wonder whether this booklet a
psychopath test and um,
I met a guy once I got into like a road
rage instance with this guy.
Um,
I've had like,
my son was one at the time and,
uh,
out of the car and I said,
my son's in the car and he said,
I don't give a fuck about your son.
And afterwards one of the psychopath
test I was a member of,
this guy's being like,
I wonder whether he was a psychopath.
I wonder whether like,
given that one of the items on the
psychopathic checklist is like grandiose
sense of self worth.
I wanted to with it with the mixed
martial artist world,
given that,
you know,
whether it's sort of attracts
psychopaths.
Well,
it certainly attracts people that aren't
opposed to violence,
right?
Because they're engaging in violence.
And um,
it also attracts people that are just,
like,
they might've been bmx riders or
skateboarders or sky divers.
They,
they love the extreme danger aspect of
it.
They're thrill seekers.
And what I,
the way I described,
I described mixed martial arts is high
level problem solving with dire physical
consequences.
And that's really essentially what it is
and these guys are attracted to these
extreme experiences.
So some of them are very pleasant
people,
some of them are very nice,
like,
like for instance,
mighty mouse.
It's probably the best pound for pound
fighter ever.
If you met him,
you would never know.
He's the best fighter in the world.
He's the sweetest guy.
So normal,
very articulate,
easy to talk to.
It doesn't get hit a lot either though.
He's so slick and smart and the way he
fights is so clever.
But some of them get hit a lot.
And uh,
you know,
now that we're knowing more and more
essentially every day about the effects
of traumatic brain injuries and
concussions and you're seeing more and
more of these stories of football
players doing crazy things.
And I'm sure you saw that recent study
where they tested 111 football players
and they found 110 of them had traumatic
brain injuries.
Wow.
Would I know that that's what they said
about Crispin Law.
Maybe that's why he.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Those guys get it for sure in.
And people say,
well,
that's fake wrestling.
Listen man,
there's nothing fake about what those
guys go through.
They might be choreographed,
they might have a bunch of things that
they're doing,
but these guys are body slamming each
other and throwing each other through
the air and landing on each other and
hitting each other with elbows.
That is a 100 percent real and they
suffer and you have to be tough to do
that.
There they are,
experiencing some severe pain forensic
exam.
He's crispin was brain forensic exam,
consistent with numerous brain injuries.
CTE,
which is found in all regions of his
brain.
Chronic traumatic encephalopathy.
I wrote a paper about crispin for the
Guardian and when it came out at 1:00
in the morning,
they a press officer for wwe phoned me
up and yelled at me,
yelled at one in the morning because I
said what that like.
I tricked the mentor,
like spending time backstage at wwe when
I was only interested in Christian.
Where you know,
did you write?
Did you go backstage before he killed
people?
No,
it was after.
It was afterwards.
Oh yeah.
The trick them.
I don't think I'd trick them.
How the fuck could they think that you
were going to put a positive spin on
someone murdering their family?
Exactly.
I thought I was going to put less
emphasis on crispin well and more
emphasis on,
you know,
the nice things about wrestling.
I know Jesus Christ,
but you knew you were going to put some
emphasis on it,
right?
Yeah.
What I was asking lots of questions.
So they must've known.
Yeah.
Speaking of Nice people,
by the way,
my porn people,
uh,
it was probably the loveliest year of my
working life's hanging out.
Really young people.
Yeah.
You feel like you've got all that work
done?
Like maybe,
I don't know,
a couple days.
Like why?
Just taking what I wanted to know.
A lot of digging.
It sounded like dicking with your
accent.
He did a lot of dicking.
I didn't know.
I didn't.
I'm sure.
Explain yourself.
I'm just joking.
I,
uh,
no it was,
it was tracing the butterfly factor,
Fabian's business plan on their world.
It was such a kind of interesting
exercise,
you know,
to,
to try and work out what's the furthest
ripple I could find,
like what light,
you know.
So Fabian has this idea about giving the
world free porn and then that leads to
that and that needs to happen at least
like where,
what's the furthest I could find the
furthest consequence.
And it was such a sort of fun exercise
coupled with the fact that being around
porn people was a little bit like being
on at a Broadway show,
backstage,
you know,
he's like,
theater people.
So coupled with all of that and the fact
that I was in la and I got to let hang
out in la.
It was,
it was really fun.
Yeah.
Can I tell you,
by the way,
one of the strangest consequences that
should address,
um,
so this um,
you know,
like pretty much every child in the
world gets learned about sex through
porn hub these days.
PORNHUB is sex education for like every
12 year old.
I'm sure as a parents probably don't go
around talking about it in time.
Exactly.
It's like,
you know,
I think when we were growing up,
maybe,
I don't know,
14 was probably about the age that we
started,
like seeing ripped up pages of playboy
and bridges and so on.
We would find them in the woods.
Okay.
I have a whole bit on,
in my act.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah,
about finding perversion was true story
I'd done literally didn't know about
perversion until I found a fucked up
magazine in the woods.
What was the magazine?
It was like a,
I think it was called foot action or
something like that.
It was very strange.
But here's what's weird,
um,
that kids today,
if you give them a phone,
like,
I mean,
what age the kids get a phone.
Like some kids get a phone at like 10
and nine.
You're essentially giving um,
porn.
Yeah.
You're giving them every awfulness that
you've given them.
Isis.
Beheading.
Yeah.
So anyway,
so I was really interested in like,
so what are the consequences of this,
of like 12 year old kids learning about
sex through porn hub.
And I found this terrible consequence in
Oklahoma.
So this was a boy called Nathan with
autism,
so he was like an awkward kid with
um,
channels like chat up a girl but didn't
know how to do it.
So he thought that the smartest,
he thought,
you know,
he thought he should text her lines of
dialogue that he'd heard in porn films.
So he texted her,
um,
first detected a bunch of Hentai porn
photographs,
um,
and she didn't respond.
So I said if she responded,
what would you have done?
And he said,
I would've stopped.
Like if she said,
can you stop sending me these,
what would you have done?
He said I would have stopped sending
them.
I just assumed she was busy.
So then he texted her line of dialogue
that he heard in a porn film and it was,
I want to bend you over and rape you
from behind.
So he is now on the sex offenders
registry for 25 years,
which means he has to live in a house
right at the edge of town because he has
to be 2000 feet away from parks and
daycare centers.
He can't go anywhere where children go.
So he can't go to football games,
basketball games,
he can't go to the Er was uh,
he was 17 and a half,
I think,
something like that,
maybe 18,
but kids as young as eight years old or
on the sex offenders registry in the
United States eat eight years old.
I had no idea.
Um,
boys and girls,
by the way,
like if you play,
there's this little boy.
Um,
they were like playing this game where
they'd take their clothes off in the
dark and then put the clothes back on
quickly.
That budget manual kits or something.
This one kid kept his clothes off when
they turned the lights on,
the girl complained to her parents.
And this boy is on the sex offenders
register.
Yeah.
Um,
so you can't like if a.
So with Nathan,
first of all,
where the fuck where the parents,
right?
You know,
on unsurprisingly,
it's like,
I think this kid was a foster kid.
So there's already like the sort of
stigma attached to the shadow of stigma.
Oh,
Nathan's a kid with autism.
So I said to this woman who like defense
children on the sex offenders registry,
I said to a light so you know,
why,
why doesn't the judge just say this is
ridiculous and throw it out of court?
And she said,
you know,
there's this kind of prevailing view
that a,
it's better to protect,
you know,
it's better to err on the side of
caution.
Um,
but also there's this prevailing view
that if a kid starts acting sexually
weird at the age of 10,
that's a precursor for them being
sexually weird when an adult maybe,
but maybe not.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
I'm sure it's true in certain cases.
I'm sure it's not true.
The consequences of sentencing and kid
like that are so extreme.
Like you should probably have a real
understanding of what's going on with
the kid and if he's autistic and he does
know what the fuck to do and he's
confused and he.
Yeah.
Well Nathan.
So he read me like his book,
He needs to like fill out this sex
offenders book like at therapy.
And so he was like,
reading me the,
cause you know,
a lot about 20 now he's going to be on
the sex offender registry for the next
23 years now.
What is it like talking to him as well?
Does your understand the consequences
weren't went down?
Yeah,
he says it's like being permanently
grounded.
He was reading me the questions,
not system,
the sex offenders book.
So it's questions like,
have you ever had a sexual situation in
which you're in or feces was involved?
And his answer was no.
And uh,
there were questions like,
have you ever had sex with animals?
And his question was like,
no.
And then the last question was when was
the last time you had sex with somebody?
And His answer was still a virgin,
a virgin on the sex offenders registry
was when you can only cost,
you can understand what the girl was
scared and I told her parents and the
parents talk to the police,
like you can tell you understand it from
the other point of view.
Oh,
100 percent.
Yeah.
But you know,
I mean,
what a butterfly effect that is.
And I'm not,
of course,
I'm not saying any of this is Fabian's
fault,
this is all had intended intended
consequences.
That's just access to sex in porn.
And you know,
the other thing that's weird as a porn
for the most part,
I mean other than this bespoke porn,
which is very specific,
but porn,
there's like levels to the depravity
that never existed before yet because
everything's keyword search.
Well at least this is what happens when
you let tech people run the world and
ramping up.
It's also people get tired of just
people kissing and then having sex.
Yeah.
So then it's like,
oh I want to watch a guy at tire grow
up.
Oh I want to watch you guys spitting the
girl's mouth.
I want to watch her get smacked around.
And then it gets weirder and gagging.
And although this is exactly that,
so that's one consequence of the
ubiquity of like Freeport and just the
sheer volume of stand out with extreme
content some way.
But the other thing is already search
engine people are sort of looking at
what's being searched for the most.
What is number one?
Well,
I tell you what,
tell you what it's like a room.
I don't know if it's an important,
but I'll tell you what's really like way
at the top.
It's anything to do with like step
sisters,
stepbrothers,
stepfathers,
step daughters,
mom's incest.
Porn is basically,
it's basically real incest away with it.
But actually when I was on the set of
stepdaughter cheerleader orgy Grazer,
the director that,
there was a bit of dialogue like these
guys will like say I go,
I think your stepdaughter is sexy,
but it kept on getting it wrong and they
were saying,
I think your daughter sexy,
but it's step that backfired.
The carriers go step daughter.
That's all there is.
We don't want to be too fucked up here.
People step,
keyword step,
go right.
Take one.
These are great people.
I've met people with great people.
Well that's nice,
you know,
and that sort of shatter some of the
stereotypes that people are about porn.
That the people are sleazy and uncaring
and doing coke and smacking each other.
This show.
Um,
if I may blow my own trumpet,
please do a,
which I learned on the set of blow my
own trumpet,
a I,
I,
I did a little bit the butterfly effect,
uh,
on stage at the ace hotel down in Los
Angeles here in Los Angeles.
And we've invited a bunch of our porn
people along and they said to us
afterwards,
like 25 years of being important,
we were the first mainstream people to
come along and not treat them as like,
you know,
ingredients in our preexisting ideology.
So not pitying them or attacking them,
just treating them on a level as a
fellow human being and isn't that kind
of nuts that,
that,
that's rare in porn because we all feel
sort of society as mainstream
journalists,
we filled these kinds of societal
pressures to,
to,
in some way attack them.
You know,
they're there to be pitied there to be
hated,
you know?
Um,
well I think you also have to establish
that you're,
your own,
whether it's moral superiority or good
taste that you don't approve of this.
You're not one of those people.
Exactly.
I'm not even a kind of sore of this
work.
Right,
exactly.
I made my excuses and left that was,
you know.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
and that means,
you know,
because of our hypocrisy,
they get exploited.
So that's why I wanted to do this show.
I'm sorry that I sort of bought it back
full circle,
but that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to do this show.
When I first moved to California,
I was on the Sitcom called news radio
and one of the guys who was a writer on
news radio was a writer for porn films
on the side.
And what it was was it didn't really pay
much,
but it gave him access to the girls and
they let him meet these girls and he was
kind of a nebbishy sort of Dorky guy and
he had never been around like a real
bomb shell girl that was willing to have
sex with them before.
So all of a sudden he's having sex these
porn stars,
but they get to have sex with these guys
on set.
And it was like some of this weird thing
that like,
this was his girlfriend,
but she would go to work and get the
shit fucked out of her by a bunch
different.
And how did they feel about that?
This is what the straw that broke the
camel's back.
He was having dinner with her and she's
like,
God,
I'm so tired.
I do an anal scene all day today.
And he was like,
what?
Like he was,
they were out to dinner and he like,
he in his mind,
he was able to put that barrier up.
And what she does is just work.
It's fine.
You know,
we're going to go to dinner and have a
wonderful time.
Candlelight,
fine wine,
some amazing food.
I didn't love with her.
She's amazing.
She was,
she was tired.
She was complaining about take it in the
ass all day and he was like,
check,
please get out of here.
So they split up.
I got another one who wasn't my friend,
but it was a friend of a friend who told
me this story that uh,
this guy was dating this girl and you
know,
it was just the same thing.
So like,
hey,
you know,
switch does relive in no big deal.
And he read or contract and he goes,
what's air tight and airtight is a dick
and every hole.
And he was like,
check please this,
I can't.
So the guy,
the first guy that took me to a set,
and this is like in [inaudible] 94.
Okay.
So this was the pretty keyword pre
fabian days,
pre Internet.
And um,
they were all rich.
Everybody was rich and the porn stars
like real stars.
It was Janine and Jill Kelly who were
very famous porn stars,
a lesbian scene.
And there was a scene,
like there was a cartoon character or
comic book character.
This woman wrote and she came to life
and they were having a lesbian scene
together.
But it was,
it was really weird because like,
um,
like she knew that we were watching and
so there was like this,
it was just like air of theatrical
enthusiasm that was very forced,
like they would do the scenes.
She's like,
I love my job,
I love my job.
My job is amazing.
Look at my friend at the time I was on,
I don't know if I'm buying all this.
I was like,
this just seems weird.
I remember Mike Quiz me on my first pool
and set this director who kind of
embedded ourselves with said to me,
you'll find that there's a wisp of
darkness dot everybody who does this
other thing.
Yeah.
Whispered.
That's what's fascinating.
Like why,
what is it like?
It's illogical.
If you look at it on paper,
it's like everyone who is healthy,
whose body functions correctly,
enjoy sexual relations,
whether it's straight sex,
gay sex or whatever the fuck it is.
People like to be touched.
It's part of being a person.
Why is it so shameful when other people
get to watch?
And why is it?
Why does it devastate people when they
find out that their loved one had done
something on film that others can see
and when they leave poor.
And this is another consequence of
Fabian I look at in my show,
is that when they leave porn,
it's much more likely that that,
you know,
they leave Poland,
they go to a different part of America,
they started a new life.
It's much more likely that they'll be
noticed then in the nineties,
like in the nineties for next porn star
to be outdated.
Someone would have to go to like a DVD
shop and Brian these days everybody just
watch his 20 poem films for five seconds
each until they found the one that they
want to jack off too.
So it's much more likely that a former
porn star will be spotted in outage.
And as a consequence by it,
like I was talking to this guy called
Dale Rutter,
his name is Dale debone and got a job as
a nurse in a hospital and human
resources code the and said to him a udl
to bone and said,
we have to fire you.
Because like with any patient says you
even like looked at the wrong way,
like they went to court.
Yeah.
So pull out a day offset that his
recognizability
has gone up massively since pornhub and
free porn came along.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be mad at the people
recognize him.
Yeah.
Pervert.
I'm just doing a job.
You fuck.
There was a woman who got arrested,
not arrested,
rather fired.
She was a school teacher and uh,
they turned,
it turned out that in the nineties or
something like that,
she'd done porn and she was like really
well respected,
very,
uh,
loved school teacher.
And then one of the kids in school
figured it out,
right.
Started telling everybody next thing you
know,
kids are getting online.
Yeah.
And watching the teacher and she lost
her job and she was like really,
really respected and loved.
And then,
you know,
we don't love you anymore.
He used to fuck.
I know,
I,
it's,
it's baffling.
You know,
even in these sort of sex positive,
more sex positive,
kind of empty slut shaming times,
there's still a massive amount.
Technically that's not real when it's a
bubble,
it's a small book that most of the world
doesn't share the ball.
That's the other thing.
It's like,
what about other countries?
Like,
is this stigma attached to the.
Wasn't there like in Italy,
uh,
a former porn star ran for PARLA
national,
started going out with um,
Oh fuck the artist Jeff Koons.
I don't know who he is.
Oh,
he's like a big,
like famous sort of pop artists and I
think they will have a relationship and
yeah,
she,
she asked you to.
Britain is still that stigma and show
Italy doesn't give a fuck.
I don't give a little wild over there.
Yeah,
I mean I would have,
I would wonder like what countries are
the most accepting of former adult
stars?
Adult is my favorite term adult.
It's like,
well,
you know,
it's like urban land only.
If you say urban used just say black
people,
Jesus Christ,
adult say porn to say porn.
And said to the adult industry,
like,
what do you mean?
The industry of people who are grown up
like,
what do you.
I play stupid like what adults as
opposed to what do the children industry
the fuck you saying?
Just a weird term.
Well I hope that the butterfly effect
because it's so just,
it just shows them to be just,
you know,
just let the rest of us ordinary,
sweet,
fucked up.
[inaudible] Nice.
You know,
mixtures of and they are just people.
I hope it will do its bit.
Do you think I should go now?
Do you think you should go now and you
said enough.
What do you think?
I think it was great.
We had a great talk.
There would be a good way to end it.
I enjoyed it very much.
I'm going to meet my family and I've got
to run it and have a low.
That's a good place.
Yes.
You do that all the time?
Good spot.
I could do every day when I'm in Los
Angeles.
Oh beautiful.
It was such a pleasure.
As always.
Let's do it again for sure.
I would love to come.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
And tell people how they could find your
stuff.
Okay,
so this new series,
it's the butterfly
effect and it's on audible,
audible.com,
a big fan of,
but I also love their.
Amazing,
here you go.
Here's the butterfly,
the biggest collection of audio
entertainment on the entire Internet.
I'm lucky that star rating.
Beautiful.
Look at you use savage.
So that's.
And my twitter thing.
It's just that drum routes and Jon
Ronson.
Yeah,
and the other thing is I wrote this
movie called Oak Joe,
which is on Netflix about giant pig on
Netflix.
Fearful.
Yeah.
Jon Ronson.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you brother.